so i felt that was a bit point
pointless on on that and like i say our
roads haven't been
fixed in the past 50 years basically
they've remained the same um
the reason for this was because we're
putting a dwelling
or another dwelling on the same title as
what we've got
and this same title was the one title
that had the other
block included in it so it didn't remain
a separate title
because we bought it off the neighbor it
got lumped in with it
we didn't get a roading contribution
back from the council because of that
it you know like would have been better
to have kept maybe that separate
and built a house on that
um now the other objection i've got to
playing this
is in 1988 we bought a block of land at
main donald's road when we bought it at
auction
it was stated that the road would be
formed
and as of yet i've not had it formed
it is just a grass paddock still when i
inquired at the council previously the
records from the old air county
were lost in a fire and they have no
record of it
we have another road riders road which
is on part of the property
that hasn't been graded for 12 months
now but a zone
request i've got to ring up to get it
graded admittedly we're the own
we are only one of two people using it
but to me that's not good enough when
we're paying the rates on it
our total rates for our property is
twenty eight thousand three hundred and
twenty dollars
of which nine thousand seven hundred
goes towards roading now this
roading has now got four houses on it
not three
and the dairy shed um now that works out
at dividing it by five nineteen hundred
and forty
dollars per property or per house
and remembering that these are farm
workers houses not
lifestylers who are using the tram road
up down the road every day
the four hectare blocks apparently pay
between 600 and 700
a year in roading rates the oxford house
that we own
pays 350 a year in roading rates now if
these people from
oxford are traveling on the tram road
every day to work
which only probably only half the
district is
then are we not subsidising them
the grading of the roads especially
norfia road walks road and sheets road
has gone from once a month to
every second month roughly now we've not
had a reduction in
rates on that we'd sooner see it
sealed and then we wouldn't have to
complain all the time on it but the
norfia road after the last rain
and grading had become more like a mud
track
rather than a
shingle road half of sheep's road has
gone from being graded
every month to every three to six months
one house down the end of it but that's
yeah i i just feel that
we have been ripped off by the amount of
rates we're paying
and the way the roads have been active
now there's another piece on
points road that has just been redone
or um patched up and already after two
months
there's already a hole formed in it now
it should not be up to the council to be
paying this cost
if cyclone can't do the job properly
then either one get rid of cycon or two
they do it at their cost
um i had we had wrote written a letter
to the council mr
dan gordon joan ward and and the two
oxford ear county
councillors uh back in june
um and we addressed one to all
councillors which
everyone should have read so really
in conclusion that i just feel either
the norfolk
well we will pay this money as long as
the the road outside the houses are
sealed
or if if not we'd like to see our
deduction in rates
you thank you mr rodden
and very clear what it is you want to
see do we have any questions
for mr ryden council stuart
thank you mr bryden um you talked about
a water test that you had
done when you did a previous um
house or what date was that
that was done when we bought the block
of land next door
and we would we had to get that done
that was done eight months before we
put in consent and it had to be within
12 months of
consent thank you
and at the time the wimac district
was testing that well because it was
below the effluent spill
that appeared last year thank you
there appear to be none um mr palmer
next steps from here
thanks mr
deputy had to stop and pause there for a
second
[Laughter]
um thank you
mr brian's raised a number of concerns
about a number of elements of
the council's business but predominantly
roading matters
there is some roading maintenance issues
which
i i know our staff have talked to at
times about some of those matters and i
haven't got an update here that i can
provide the counselors
in respect of but that is one matter
whatever the level of service
that the council decides for its
particular roading network
we should ensure that that's delivered
on if we're not then we need to address
that
so that is something we need to follow
up in our routing team
the more substantive matter which mr
brydon
brings to us about the development
contribution
it is eroding contribution that is
applied to
every dwelling in the district any new
dwelling or any new lot
created for the purposes of residential
development or for that matter
commercial development
incur that same roading development
contribution
and mr brydon makes reference to
a couple of roads which he was advised
by staff or a couple of projects tram
road and
ashley bridge that contribution actually
contributes to a far wider range of
projects than just that but i would
appreciate from mr brydon's perspective
very few of those i sent it anywhere
near his
main his property is at prison
uh that is a council policy if the staff
don't have a delegation to
um to waive that charge so only
you if you felt so minded to would be
able to do that and for us to do that we
would need to bring a report to you as
council
in respect to that matter so if that's
what you would
like us to do then we we can do that for
your consideration
thank you mr palmer uh how does council
feel about
raising a report on this matter is there
any
any indications
i feel as a need counsellor
ah thank you mr deputy mayor i've got to
get it right
um i i i would be uh in favour of a
report coming to us
to address the issues that mr brydon has
raised
it may or may not be favorable for mr
briden and the outcome but i think it's
something that we need to look at
to make sure there are no errors or
mistakes
and that what is being applied to him um
is fair
over in context and it may be it is i
don't know i don't have that information
i think mr brydon is talking about
fairness and the levels of service
and i i think he's taken the time to
come along and talk to us
that a report would be useful that we
could consider
um i echo that sentiment i think that um
there's absolutely no harm in and
looking into this further with a report
and you know there does seem to be some
inequities there that he's that he's
discussed with us
and um i would like to see that delved
into a bit more deeply
okay no objection to that appears to be
none so
we will request a report back to us mr
brian which will inform us of
exactly your case and make a ruling on
that report
then yes
as for final consent sign off on the
house has not been done because we
haven't paid for the
roading contribution so we'll let
we have been threatened that that
roading
because we're waiting for the
contribution
the consent will not be done so we put
on hold and we'd have to reapply
will that be put on hold do you know
what mr brighton says is not unusual for
where there are where there are still
contributions
i accept that they are contested in this
case where contra in the normal sense
when contributions are
unpaid then code of compliance would
usually be withheld until such time as
they are paid
i i think i think the council's position
on that
we will try and get a report back to its
next month's council meeting so with
that we can
consider the code compliance matter at
that same time
if that's the only matter that's
outstanding in regards to the code
compliance i presume you've
had final inspection and that's been
given a tick
yeah okay we'll look into that element
as well
thank you right well thank you mr broden
um
we'll we'll let you know when that's
happening and you
may wish to come along and listen to to
uh when that
report is presented of which you're most
welcome um we'll be in a public meeting
i would imagine
um we'll be in the in the public meeting
so you're welcome to come along and
listen to
to that being presented and we will see
where we go from there
thank you very much for taking the time
to come see us thank you
i have no attuned business on the uh
on the agenda there is no covet
report uh covert 19 report this month
apart from the fact that we will be
talking
probably a little bit about that in the
public excluded
shovel ready project discussion a little
later
so that will come up then um item
7 7.1 duncan
welcome
and that is pages 55-78
thank you mr deputy mayor uh good
afternoon everyone um
the purpose of this report is to provide
uh annual update
on progress with the regeneration
projects
reasonably successful year for the
regeneration program in the last year
a number of projects completed
and a number also soon to complete as
well
although the overall messages our
planned expenditure is still
tracking slightly behind where we where
we would like to be
we are catching up and um
i expect that by the end of this current
financial year we'll basically be caught
up with our
capital project spend um to where we
where we plan to be
so um another key thing uh
that's happened in the last year
obviously the
disestablishment of the regeneration
steering group so most matters now
uh being considered through the kai poi
to ewe community board
majority of the work in kaiapoi east
uh regeneration area is soon to complete
and
it's probably fair to say that there's
almost a shift of focus to the kaibwe
south regeneration area where
um majority of the projects over the
coming year in a bit will be down in
that area
the report a lot of facts and figures
um i won't go through all those happy to
just take
questions if there are any on that um
there's a wee summary though on um page
57 just
the pie chart there just showing you the
general status of how we're progressing
overall for all of the projects
in the program and that includes the um
projects in the kaiboy wharf and marine
precinct area as well
there's some just on page
59 in section 4.11
just got a list at the bottom there
there's a few projects there that are
either
on hold um or or delayed
or behind schedule some of those
uh now we've uh have been deliberately
pushed back as a result of the
re-planning
following the covered
lockdown
probably won't talk much more on those
it's probably reasonably fresh from the
last meetings you had page 61
in section 4.15 um we've got a section
there just on key
actions or items requiring resolution
the first one there heritage of mangakai
we actually have a report to
the mahitahi uh committee later this
month
um just setting out those co-government
co-governance
arrangements and talking through the
concept plan so
it's good to make a start uh finally on
on that project
and that will run over the next four odd
years
uh the rural land uses establishment um
is a work on with the community board
obviously with the
whale aqua sports proposal
that factors in some of those decisions
around rural land use for a big chunk of
rural land areas
the war memorial area landscaping has
now been deferred
the rowing precinct project is still on
hold at the moment because that's
subject to us
advancing the discussions in the project
with the kaiapoi croquet club relocation
uh we will come back to you with the
club rooms business cases council
requested
reserve naming we think that we'll be
able to
accelerate that a bit now through uh the
heritage of mangakai project
as well a lot of it relates to getting
rinanga approval of some of the names
we've proposed there for the reserves so
other than that um
oh sorry we'll just draw attention
perhaps to table
seven uh which is on page 65. that's
just a summary of
um the the recent and current projects
um related to the norman kirk park area
in kaiapoi east
any projects associated with that like
the road upgrades and the enabling works
we've already done
at the moment our forecast there just
for those projects
is actually tracking to around 205
000 over budget
we are working on that still to try and
bring that into line that does
include a hundred thousand dollars of
remaining contingency for those projects
and most of them are actually nearly
finished so we're hoping we don't need
to dip into that
uh that also does include um 105 000
of costs that were directly related to
covert 19 delays
on the contract so apart from those that
would have been on track
and then the next table table 8 which is
just related to the
marine project specifically they are on
track at the moment to come in
on budget so
happy to answer any questions if there
are only thank you duncan for a full
report
uh council williams
hi duncan i just i'm willing you could
fill us in a wee bit of information
on the leasing of the um the pontoons we
had some
interest originally um we got um
people um contracted to take
sites to my knowledge
uh there were originally four
uh i'd say tangible responses
council limbs can you just turn
responses to the original um request for
um expressions of interest uh
i'd need to get an update from green
space team who look after the moorings i
know they were
working with at least one
who i understood was not far away but
there's no
no signed agreements at this stage to my
knowledge but
i could find out from the green space
team and provide an update to
councillors after the meeting if you
like
yep just just further to that
uh duncan i just wonder whether that
group
that um dealt with that in the first
place could be recalled and
just have a further look at what's
happening around that space
yes group that's there thanks
um yes duncan just curious about the bmx
line it's got
n a for the difference
sorry it's just feedback and you've got
a 99 000
budget and you've said you've only spent
seven and a half but you've got n a is
the
difference can you just explain why we
don't have 90 000 credits
uh yeah that one's because that was
actually an externally funded
project it was 100 externally funded so
the 99
was perhaps uh an excess carryover from
the previous year so the bmx
project came in on budget uh 99 000
got carried over but we only actually
needed seven and a half thousand so
it's not actually
it's not actually a money left over that
we can
use to balance against the other
projects
because as i say more budget was carrick
there was actually previous spending in
the previous years
um that took that project right up to
its full budget of 310
000 but
shouldn't that reduce the figure in that
column the first column then
really you should have that figure
showing us just 7516
yes yes yes could have done that um yeah
that's the the budget is what's shown in
our financial system at the moment
but yeah the money was actually spent in
previous years and the only reason that
that
line is treated different to the others
is because it was a 100
externally funded project just wonder
then duncan in the in the next report if
you could just
have a paragraph to explain that sure
any further questions do we have a mover
for the report
moved councillor blackie i'm happy to
second
um duncan's covered it all very well
progress is as good as the weather and
covert allow and i'm pretty happy
thank you thank you duncan for
a full report like you normally normally
supply to us it's pretty
self-explanatory but
uh that piece that councillor bunnett is
inquired
on i think um could just do with a
little bit of a little bit of an
explanation in the next one
so thank you any further speakers
write a reply i'll put that all those in
favor
against carried thank you
next report is 8.1
linley really
pages 79 to 110 the draft
symmetry strategy
thank you good afternoon this report
seeks your approval to go out for public
consultation on the summit the draft
cemetery strategy
i think i've seen most of you at either
the boards and at the briefing that you
are well aware of that we were
developing the strategy
and now's the time to consult with our
community as to what they think about
the management
and ongoing um
looking after our cemeteries and what
they want as our
community changes and
i'm hoping that we should this should
all be fairly straightforward for you
one thing i will say is the graphs on
page eight
there is an error in the calculation and
i will be updating those graphs
this afternoon prior to this document
going out for consultation
i had underestimated how much
availability of lean we had so
that will be updated and go out in the
consultation document
so be happy to answer any questions if
you have them
mr marie
i'm not too sure if i can actually um
ask questions saying i own a plot
or two plots so have i got a conflict of
interest
no i can't stand on them
just with this report going ahead
i'm just interested with the virtual
cemetery um
where there's no ashes option there what
is the
the ruling you know beside that one
with
there's no um dedicated ashes plots
at that cemetery but people are still if
they've got a family plot they can inter
ashes there so that means that any any
local person that wants to be
buried there have they have to buy a
full-size plot
like what used to happen in oxford it's
not quite that straightforward
if you've if you have a plot with a
burial in it
you can into ashes in that plot yes
but you can't buy a burial plot just to
put ashes in
right
interesting supplementary to that why
well it's about the use of space really
um
if you if you're just entering ashes and
and burial plots then you're going to
fill up the cemetery really quickly
because each burial plot is of a size
to take a casket so
it's about managing space and there may
well be
i don't know the birch hill cemetery
very well i have been there
there may well be an area where an ashes
and two material could be built but
um it wouldn't be a good idea to start
just allowing
burial plots to be used for ashes only
can i that was the reason why i'm asking
is because it's not really a large well
it's not
it's not no and that was why i'm just
asking
why is council not looking seriously at
having
ashes you know a smaller plotty wrap
with ashes can be
used it's not something that has been
considered
before but this is certainly the
opportunity to do that
and if the councillors felt or the
oxford boards felt that
that was warranted and there was space
for it then
this consultation this strategy
certainly gives you the opportunity to
do that thank you
councilman um
reading through some of my local
government news today i i know the
government are consulting on burials and
cremation and is any of that legislation
likely to
affect our strategy at all considering
that the consultation is
out at the moment
last year we can we submitted to
the consultation on the burial
incrementation act
and yes if some of the suggestions they
have in that consultation document
uh brought into uh into force it could
have significant impact
upon our management of cemeteries but
it's really about the management the
day-to-day management
rather than the strategic direction for
this council around
available cemetery land and that higher
level management of that land
and acquisition if needed um so we're
keeping a
an eye on that piece of work that's
going through it's
not due to close now until october i
think
um so i would imagine it'll be early to
mid next year before we actually get
any legislation actually coming through
but yes we are keeping an eye on it but
we are going to develop a policy is in
conjunction with this strategy
and that will certainly be the place i
would imagine if there are any changes
legal changes that we will have to take
account of them
in the policy itself i guess just
supplementary so there's no danger if
someone
um gives you a submission at this moment
in time
and we react to it that then that goes
against the actual
policy that the government's going to
put into legislation there's no risk of
that
i think there's always a chance of a
risk
but these strategies are like any
document that the council has if we need
to amend them
put in an extra piece um we can do that
on request or as required
so where it's not stuck for the next six
years we can react
as the changes in legislation come
through
council many i think most of my
questions have kind of
been covered with um wendy's subsequent
ones but
um yeah i would definitely be interested
in seeing
us look into ash's
in tournament in the virtual cemetery
but but my question is you said that
ashes can be entered
in an existing grave so so where a
family member has previously deceased
and has been buried there then you can
you can enter ashes
of subsequent family members in the same
on the same plot
yes okay thank you
council reading ah thank you
i just wondered what seemed
an easy matter becomes quite complicated
could you clarify the demand and
relation
for burial requirements are reservations
reserved plots included or taken into
account
in your projected demand yes
so the demand would have been reduced by
the level of
pre-sold plots
yeah i would i will check on that but
yes i think that's
that's what i did i have to go back to
my spreadsheet i've
as a as i said i've um found a
miscalculated so i'm
redoing it now so i'll go back and check
that to ensure that that's happening
right thank you second question um
you've
asked that we impose a moratorium um
why would should that be necessary
we actually um we have one on at the
moment
and we put that there just when the
covert measures came into
effect um because at that time
nobody knew what the pandemic was going
to
turn out like so that motorium is still
there
once you start discussing cemeteries
it may encourage people to to go in and
reserve plots which
would just exacerbate the issue about
their being
sufficient plots available the other
thing is in this
coming ltp you'll probably be looking at
reviewing the fees which again could
result in a lot of plots being reserved
so we felt that while these discussions
are taking place
and it's given the council the
opportunity to
to to get to understand the supply and
demand
situation a little better it was a good
idea to
just not reserve plots at the moment
council broke thank you my question was
about the moratorium as
as well you don't envisage that that's
going to cause a problem
the fact that we haven't had
reservations for so long
as far as staff is concerned it hasn't
caused the problem so far
where there is a burial then we're
allowing
reserve plots um in conjunction with
that burial so for example
this the spouse of somebody who dies can
reserve a plot
and um there hasn't been a demand
or any issue about not being able to do
that
just a quick one again on birch hill
sorry just looking at there's no land
there's 33 and 75 we're making 108 so i
take it
there's 108 burial places available
birch hill
and that's and then it's full yeah
counselor duty
just one more question please with the
cast
west eastern cemetery um bearing in mind
that um you've got two areas up there
which is the
there's two different levels one's
presbyterian and one's anglican i think
whatever yeah someone's someone's higher
higher
up than the other um the the thing that
i need to know
is that with each of those areas are
there is there enough
land to to grow and develop
more sites for both areas
there's actually a lot of land in there
yeah i see there's a lot of land here
yeah it's a big l-shaped piece of land
so this yeah there's plenty of room
there
thank you well they have some
recommendations someone removed council
of duty
seconded council councillor duty
thank you i just would like us
at some stage to have a little bit more
discussion on this because i can see
where we need to perhaps tidy things up
a little bit more
but that's up to the community at large
to
make recommendations as well the um
and just the the other thing really as
i've said we've
we've ordered two plots and we've got
but we've done that
in hindsight so that would our children
don't have to make that decision
and i think you'll find that a number of
people have done that
so that the families don't have to go
through that trauma of finding a plot
when the time comes around and that was
really the only reason why
i thought you were going to get away
early didn't you 8.2
yeah yes mr martin
it's actually one one one two three one
three two
all right good afternoon uh so there are
three components to this item
one is a cover report which gives a
little bit of background
to this issue and how it comes to be
before you
the second is a draft uh climate change
policy
and the third attachment is as an
attachment as an extract
from a regional format
for a initial climate change risk
screening that
my macro district council was party to
back end of last year early this year as
a regional initiative
really the purpose of this initial
policy
statement is to ensure the council has
in the public domain a uh
an as i say an initial statement
that acknowledges the significance of
this issue
and in the context of part of the policy
sets out the suite of actions that it
proposes
to take over over time
to address this issue as you know this
is
a a particularly difficult
issue in the sense of some very
significant long-term implications
building over time but the effects of
climate change are evident in the short
term and in the um
policy and legislation space it is
moving
uh quite quickly as well and some of you
will recollect the announcement
yesterday of the
first national level risk screening
for climate change vulnerabilities in
new zealand
the suggestion is to seek some initial
community
views on this draft policy
let's see the extent and nature
of that feedback but
a view would be to then leave the draft
to lie on the table
and as i draft and to consider when you
are considering the long-term plan in
march
for a release in march next year a more
substantial
consultation in relation to this issue
it will
you will see begin to impact some of the
budget provisions
uh for the for the draft long term plan
between now and then the second and
third stages of the regional
climate change risk assessment will be
completed so we will have
a new tranche of information there will
be
a government confirmed through the
september elections
and we will get to see what the national
programme from what would inevitably be
in time a speech from the throne as to
how
the incoming government proposes to
address that in the next
three years so this is a contingent
approach that we're recommending
and but it is important we felt
and the climate change portfolio holder
in discussion with
uh councillor mailings in the mayor that
there
is in the public domain a uh
a statement of intent by the council
in this area happy to answer any uh
questions
thank you so i'm just um sometimes
things get mixed up between
sustainability and climate change i just
wonder if you could explain just
why we're dealing with this in isolation
sure so
you'll also recall
that the council has a first stage
climate uh
sustainability strategy and that that
is in scope is
at the corporate level which is about
council sustainability practices
and its role in that regard as an
organization
and it also in recent monitoring
reporting on the implementation of that
has highlighted and you've had a
briefing about
further pushing that out into stage two
and then again into stage three
so that is a parallel piece of work
um which is um probably more focused
around the emissions management side of
things as it relates to climate change
whereas the climate change response
strategy is
going to be much more dealing with
adaptation
so how does a council adapt its
substantial
investment on behalf of the community
and infrastructural assets
over time as climate change impacts
become more significant and obviously
particularly in the coastal zone
and we also have a further strand of
work through the district plan
so in time as each of those
components of sustainability and climate
change are further progressed
there will come a time when from a staff
point of view we will recommend to you
integrating all of that into an
overarching strategic framework
but each of those components are moving
at slightly different
paces in different ways at the present
point in time
and uh there is uh there is a
space there in terms of climate change
at the moment uh any questions
council barnett
just a couple of questions simon the
the climate change response amendment
act is predominantly focused on zero
carbon although
adaptation comes later so how is our
climate change strategy linked to a zero
carbon strategy
so there are a couple of angles to that
one is
our response strategy uh in terms of
adaptation will be
will be principally led out of our
district plan work
and out of our infrastructural strategy
and implement an asset
asset management however
i think there's a reasonable expectation
that
um local government local authorities
will be being asked
through the climate change commission
work
to play a role in a mission emissions
management and we can reasonably expect
that the national emissions reduction
targets under zero carbon as they are
progressively put in place
there will be a role for local
authorities
in both facilitating advocating
and through our own actions supporting
that
to achieve that very ambitious national
target of
zero carbon by 2050 i hope that
addresses your question
not really so why does our climate
change policy not include zero carbon
as an object so there is an element of
that included in the current
sustainability strategy
the question that will come to you
before you
is in terms of the future role of the
council and emissions reduction
is you consider extending that
sustainability strategy into the whole
amber of the council's operations and
then take that to the community
and remembering what we said
collectively was
we need to show practice and leadership
in our own behaviours before we go out
to the community
and i'm expecting that those subsequent
stages of the sustainability strategy
will flesh out that strand of work
around them what's the council's role
in emissions reduction
and as i say i'm i'm i can
i'm not i don't know the exact time but
i think it's reasonable to expect
there will be some pretty ambitious
local and regional emissions reductions
targets that are set
and then embedded into local government
performance targets
so my sick offer opens
under the draft climate change policy
one of the policy objectives
is to provide for a planned approach to
reducing emissions that contribute to
climate change
and adapting to its effects on
communities and environment so i think
it does
in a in some way it's one of the major
policy objectives
and again
under 5.3
implementation and monitoring regularly
measure corporate emissions and lead by
example in reducing those so
there is oh and 5.2 which is strategy
and planning
ensure that low carbon climate resilient
development is adopted as a key tenant
of urban growth and development and land
use decisions so i think there is the
expectation
that it will address it and i think as
simon said
uh the more we work on the projects the
more you'll find that they're better
integrated
look my apologies stay there pj my
apologies
um uh while my name's on the front of
this report uh vj's done most of the
heavy lifting
in terms of the work that's gone behind
it
it was just that at the time it made the
agenda bj was
on leave so just just a comment then
would it be possible
in the introduction for that also to be
included in the introduction because the
first thing you read
doesn't actually say anything about that
in the introduction on the climate
change policy would it be possible to
add something
is that being another objective of the
policy
because it only mentions adaptation okay
all right
and the second question i had sorry with
your indulgence mr
mr deputy um the
adaptation policy should there be a
separation between
us adapting with council-owned
infrastructure and assets and privately
owned infrastructure and assets
um i think i certainly think there
there is uh in time through a full
response strategy a very specific
reference to the council's assets
i say the council's assets but the
community's assets
in the council stewardship that are
collectively owned
from uh private assets people's homes
and their their other other and business
investments
i think apart from our district plan
uh responsibilities um
the and it's given added point by the
discussion that's come in the media out
of the
national policy national assessment that
was released yesterday
where does the responsibility lie and
and that's a conversation that is still
very very
uncertain and fluid um
well i could sorry to not go on too long
there is some emerging practice frankly
which is a third or third third
and that's being led in the bay of
plenty
where basically uh central government is
accepting a third of the financial
responsibility around adaptation
local government is accepting a third or
council
some councils have accepted a third i
can't say local government
uh and and private property owners
and those sort of propositions are
current discussions
i'm not saying that's right or wrong
it's just that
that is that is starting to become
we're starting to get down to the
business end of investments
in flood protection or
retreat where those sort of funding
formulas are starting to be
discussed i would stress that's in the
absence of any
particular legislation or
agreement but but we're into it already
i mean i could add a further comment to
that that yes
we did discuss the scope of the policy
and
thought that we would have a starting
point looking at council's business
because
um of the sheer scale of the project
really but however
having said that under policy objectives
our key policy objective too is to
enable the council to provide
transformational leadership
that will ensure the long-term
well-being sustainability and resilience
of the district's communities and
businesses so i think
that the scope of their objective is
broad enough
once we start getting in the detail we
you know
the council is the community so we do
need to look at
how we can make the communities more
resilient
thank you ej
council blackie
um simon you talked about some
the inter inter-reaction of climate
change and
sustainability and hinted that one day
they'll merge the form one
how are you going to put this out as a
statement of it sure it's just only a
statement of intent but going out for
consultation
how do you put that out to the public
without bringing natural hazards in
as part of that trio i can't see how you
can separate natural hazards from the
discussion
it's it's it's got really good quest
question counselor in it in it
everything's interconnected with
everything else that's what makes an
ecosystem and that's
the whole issue of sustainability that
it's all about
um uh i do think however that there is a
sufficient
and i probably point to a degree to the
community
view feedback that we've got through the
survey
there is a level of awareness about the
specificity of
climate change that is enough
for us to be uh to be
and needing to engage on that
specifically
to i don't think we're ready to to have
a wide-ranging community
conversation at this point in time
around sustainability in the round
i don't think we've done enough work and
i'm conscious that
about how do we find the right balance
between
ensuring there is
awareness and understanding and a policy
direction around climate change
from all of the other elements of
sustainability and
i would point to sustainability isn't
just about other aspects of the natural
environment it's about our economic
sustainability
about social cohesion and social
development in the district
and that becomes a very big and wide
topic so
i do think i do think we need to
take a stepped approach to this but i do
acknowledge
there is the potential for people to say
well what about
x y or z and let's let's
our recommendation is to put this out uh
albeit with some amendments now and get
a first round
reaction from the community to it and if
that's saying
we want to we want to talk to more about
this we want to talk about it in the
context of wider sustainability
objectives then we'll bring that
feedback back to you and make a
subsequent recommendation as to how to
do that
in the light of that we've got 20
something pages here
how did how concise and and focused a
format do you intend to put that out to
the public because i
i think the amount of info there will
just overwhelm them sure
so we would not uh our focus would be
using
the digital platform that we now have
and some of you will recall
the res the report results that we
presented to you
circulated to you around the recovery
planning topic
we would make the uh that a pretty brief
digital
website presentation but we'd have the
supporting information that is available
for those people who want to see
see and know more about it so our
challenge will be to
produce a cogent short narrative for a
web page that
picks the eyes out of a climate change
policy issue
but then gives you links to the layered
information that supports that
my question is for us for council is
how are we going to manage serving our
large network of roads if we've got to
get down to this
zero emissions
uh that's a pretty
pretty big question for us all um
and and uh
there are a lot of unknowns in the space
and a lot of questions that council will
have a central government
that the community will have of the
council uh
that householders have about what's my
role in this
um uh and and i readily acknowledge that
that that challenge but but
collectively there's something like uh
the thick end of a billion dollars of
community infrastructural assets
that to greater or lesser degrees will
will be impacted
and uh you may recall we
we're party to a local government new
zealand assessment of the vulnerability
of our assets
and i think for waimakariri district
that was of the order of seven or eight
hundred million dollars worth of assets
now that's not just to not scare people
that's not to say
they become useless or they're
non-functional
but those are assets that are in
positions and situations that are
vulnerable to the impact of climate
change
and as part of the work on asset
management planning and our
infrastructure strategy
we need to um more closely assess that
and what that means and what are the
mechanisms
that are uh or the options that are in
place
last very quick comment uh
it will come at a time and we're not
ready to have that conversation
yet i don't think with the community
about
uh what to defend how to adapt
and where to retreat and that's pretty
clear from the national assessment
that that's a conversation that needs to
be had
with the new zealand community pretty
soon i guess we're all
right now reeling from the impacts of
covert 19
and getting a head back above the
parapets in terms of the other
bigger picture longer term strategic
issues so
but now's not the right time for that
would be our view
but it needs to be soon and prince i
could add to that the climate change
response strategy
in the sustainability strategy we're
going to have to do some serious
thinking about some of that stuff like
for example
as far as i'm aware these things we
currently do like purchasing pipes
there's not as far as i'm aware there
isn't the technology
at the moment to offset the carbon
emissions that are made in producing
those pipes so
we need to look at strategies like do we
plant more to offset
the cost that you know we reduce the
cost as much as we can but there's a
point we can't go any further so
what do we do to offset those do we have
you know there will be budget
budgetary implications of we might have
to start paying for some of those
emissions and so on and so on so that's
certainly stuff that
any strategy will need to look at
in terms of a possible range of
responses to those issues
thank you um this question for himself
is around
this report and given you've given us
the explanation of the difference
between climate change and
sustainability
you need on top of that is the next
report of which
is consultation as well is there how do
you think our public's going to go
between confusion of the next report
on natural hazards as well as going out
on climate change at the same time for
consultation
and look i absolutely accept the
argument that there is no good time
um yeah i accept that but yeah these are
pretty close
they they are and i i'd have to say i
think these
the next report on natural hazards we
should get going on the engagement
around that
uh first and i
will get it out of the way but but but
provide a clear run for that
uh we have a more discretion i think in
timing about
when and and how to go out with the
community on this
this wide arranging higher level kind of
document
sorry two two more questions that have
popped up during the discussion
and when i look at some of the table
in the back there seems to be a lot of
items that i would consider regional
council responsibilities
how are we going to will this is this
table part of the document that's going
to be released
to the public obviously it's in the
public view um but how are we going to
confuse regional versus territorial
responsibilities in this climate
strategy or
are we even worrying about that uh right
now we're
probably not worrying about that it's a
it's a initial first pass risk
assessment
um but i think you highlight an issue
about what will be the future role and
relationship between regional councils
and district
or city councils in this area and
that's that's that's uh that's a
conversation that isn't easy to
to encapsulate in in in the short term
second question was
at some point earlier in the term we
asked that every report
comes that comes to us does have a
climate change
uh category in it is that has that been
progressed or discussed
so i i have a piece of work that i'm
hoping to complete
by the end of august which will be some
modifications to our report template
your report template
which sets out provides for a more
specific
at the moment it's implicit under the
title community implications
and we want to in that section of the
reports that you receive we want to
tease that out a little bit
so to make that uh those connections
i think it's helpful to have had
a dr have a draft climate change policy
to refer to to as a reference point
uh in those reports so to some extent
it's appropriate that this comes before
we
um and it's no disrespect to colleagues
but what do i say about this
how much do i say uh how much is needed
needing to be said
and i regret that in some respects we'll
be telling you more about what we don't
know
than what we do know so it's finding
i'm wrestling with a little bit of
balancing and that template update and
i've we've been looking at other
councils
and how and and how they have
have wrestled with that i'll have that
with you soon
good questions and you have a question
uh council reading
ah thank you mr deputy mayor um in this
policy
um somewhere it says we give effect to
the principles of the treaty of
white tangi
the principles as i understand it the
partnership protection and participation
how does this policy align with the
naitahu
anchoring the foundation strategy
are we all on the same page and working
together
so the naitahi strategy is a really high
level
strategy that sets out their vision for
the future
of their people and
they to get into more strategic
actions they were going to go and do a
whole lot of consultation in the in the
various runanga
um so certainly at a very high level
document that they've got there's
nothing inconsistent with it
thank you well i've been good questions
and um so do we have a mover for the
recommendation to move
moved council emailing second to the
council of barnett council meetings
you guys have all asked some excellent
questions and and there are nothing but
questions questions and more questions
when it comes to this because it's huge
it is the single
biggest thing that is facing
everywhere right now we don't have all
the answers yet
but we do need this statement of intent
we're not sheltering people from
anything by telling them we're not
telling them anything right now because
people are already
having this these conversations in the
public discourse
you know people are ready and waiting
for us to take action because councils
are
at the forefront of this they are at the
coalface of climate change we are the
ones who
have the first response to actually do
something at a local level
and you know what's that phrase um think
globally act locally where local
this is where it starts so you know i
mean we have repeatedly signaled our
interests in acting proactively to
climate change for a number of years
through a whole bunch of things
since about 2011. um you know
there's a whole number of legislative
instruments that also direct us to take
action
other councils are already doing this so
you know as this report says in
3.6 council business and on climate
change needs to be embedded
into council and not treated as an
add-on
we need our community to know we are
working on this space
we also need to cover our obligations
and seek to reduce
any legal and financial risks that we
might encounter through any failure to
act
or adopt a policy so i think that really
um it's a no-brainer to
adopt this statement of intent and i
would like to move that we
um i would like to move to a through d
so thank you yes as councilor mailing
says this is a very very large topic and
it's very very important that we have
something
in writing that has a clear um
aim that we're going to keep this at the
front of our mind going forward
for the next 50 years at least and
ongoing
what concerns me a little bit though is
i i understand other councils are doing
a lot in this space
but that's because they have immediate
needs they have houses washing into the
sea
i've lived in hawke's bay and i've seen
what the floods have been doing in the
harmona area
for years and it's getting worse um so
they have houses falling off and off
cliffs and houses falling off into the
sea
we are fortunate we are not in that
position right at this moment
um we are seeing incremental changes and
we're seeing changes in weather
patterns but it's not as immediate and
it makes it harder for our community to
actually realize we have to do something
about this going forward
but i think it's really important to
note that the developments in our
coastal areas were approved well before
climate change was even talked about
it's not this council's fault that those
developments were approved
and what we need to do now is focus on
local government's role
in well-being and looking after our
community
but i'm very cautious about us saying
that we have funding
to do this when it comes to private
assets we have to look after the
community assets that's our
responsibility we're charged to do it
but with private assets we've got to
have a much wider conversation
and so yes we need to lead we need to
advocate we need to facilitate
but funding is going to be an ongoing
issue and an ongoing question
and i would like to see more direction
from national
um from central government than we've
seen to date
because at that at this moment in time
that question is largely unanswered
thank you councilman any further
speakers appear to be none
council medics who write a reply
i don't actually think there's much more
to say about that
i will put the motion all those in favor
against
carrie thank you
now mr young this time
pages 133-442 natural hazards report
you may
thank you
thank you mr deputy mayor um
this report in front of you uh has many
many pages to it and i don't intend
to work you through all of those
you have been fairly well briefed about
this matter uh at a
two or three briefings in particular to
the dpnr committee
and i think you're generally well aware
of the information
that is being attached to this report
and also the intention for why this
report is in front of you
in order that we can more freely release
this information and make it available
to
our public so i won't spend any more
time on that i think the two
matters which probably are a little more
pertinent for
a discussion today is at the recent
briefing and i wanted to
point this out even though it's in the
report at the recent briefing there was
a request for the staff to pull together
a bit of a summary
of assumptions and you will have noted
in the report
that this report does not do that and
when i began that particular task i
identified that
each of these modeling reports has
dozens of of assumptions underlying
the information and i felt it became
difficult and even
actually risky to attempt to pull some
of those together
in a document that was released because
it implies then that they are the only
important assumptions
uh and that anything that isn't included
in the summary document of course
uh can't be all that important and so i
um
had not put that together here however i
think the primary
objective of the query that came during
that briefing
was to ensure that the information that
is being
put out has adequate explanation
available to ensure that appropriate
interpretation is made of it
so what we've undertaken to do there is
ensure that
there is appropriate guidance given
actually
in the electronic version
where people can view this information
so that there is
explanatory bullet points out to the
side
that will make sure that uh some of
these key points
which were raised by both yourself and
councillor stewart at the time
are made clear to any anybody who's
wanting to
view that information i think the second
point that will be worth some discussion
and i think it's probably best led by
questions from the council rather than
myself is with regard to the planned
consultation
and you all would have received um
correspondence from a council of barnet
who was
raising some you know very good issues
about why particular choices were made
and i think in particular in light of
the discussion we've just had
i i think there is a real need to ensure
that
firstly the different
the communication on the different
matters is clear and in context
as as we discuss it with the community
and secondly it would be useful to get
guidance
from um the council today
as as to the extent they felt it was
appropriate for us to engage
with the community on this what you see
in front of you is the
the communications plan as it currently
stands drawn up by the communications
manager
but it will be worthwhile and we will be
very happy to engage with you
on what level you feel is appropriate
both for this and and also any other um
context that that needs to happen within
and that's why i have asked trevor along
it's
effectively it's his baby in terms of
this
underlying information and also as
you're well aware trevor
has a larger engagement process in the
wings with regard to the proposed
district plan
and it is important that both of those
matters are thought about uh as as we
undertake this release i don't know if
you have anything to add to
um i had a question first up and it was
just
uh just around that consultation and
given that
the people who will be alerted to the
effects of this
will be the customers of builders and
developers
do think it would be pertinent to be
targeting
builders developers and uh and so on
associated businesses if you like
targeting them with this information and
where to go to have a look at it because
they are the ones
who will be the ones that are dealing
with average joe blogs probably won't
know anything about it
until you say that you have to raise
your four level by 1.5 meters
and it'll be the builder or the
developer who actually
uh alerts their customer to that so i
just
there's no nothing in in this plan that
says that we're going to target
that particular area and my viewers they
will be the ones that will need it
more than anybody uh thank you look we
don't have the benefit of alistair grey
here today
to to talk this through with you he put
the comms plan together in conjunction
with the project team
uh mr chair very good point certainly
there's certainly targeted um
emails or consultation to certain groups
but i guess some of the uh organizations
and builders on that that use this
information might benefit from it
um uh we'll certainly look into that see
if we can see what we can do there
thank you my question follows on from
what the deputy mayor has
sort of been talking about i i note that
we're going out for
consultation during october which is a
couple of months away
and um in the recommendation we have g
which says note staff will be updating
the information on limbs as a result of
this work
where where is the update at the moment
is it
because you've done this information is
it already being fed through
onto limbs or do you do this exercise
and then
start the update because i mean that is
immediately going to trigger
public response and they know
generally people don't know anything
about this at the moment
and it may be if you're already staying
to update limbs that'll be the first
time they'll see it
so we held we've held two or three staff
internal meetings since the briefing and
that identified in particular
well a range of tasks that fell out of
that and one of those was for the
manager planning and regulation nick
harrison
who has the task of of ensuring that the
limbs and pims
will be brought up up to date that
task will take place after this
particular meeting
and i understand also that the intention
is that the
limbs will the the wording on the limbs
will be more generic it won't be sort of
property specific
it'll be along the lines of this this
property may be subject to flooding and
there is information
available uh on the council website
for you know the for the applicant to to
look into further
so it won't be going down to a property
specific saying you're at risk you're
not at risk
it'll just be alerting people to that
particular issue so it may not in fact
change the wording may not change that
much
from what it already is where it does
those general sort of words
are already included in the limbs and
pimps
just um i'm just moving on a wee bit
from the
geological hazards for the earthquakes
and such like now
i know we were going to have a seminar
or
a bit but then covet 19 got on the way
are we going to still bring that
that earthquake scenario
back into the community again that one i
think it was lincoln college did it
sorry i don't recall the specific what
we have done is we have been in touch
with the university
and they have provided information to us
which have updated the particular hazard
maps
uh but sorry simon you may have
sorry counselor you might be thinking of
the
af8 exercise yes so
some of you will recall sitting in the
downstairs yes and hearing the folk
from that project giving you an update
and i think there was an
intent by the university to offer that
into the community
and then life changed yes uh so we can
certainly go to oxford
yeah we can see in particular concern
counselor about
the scenario what does it mean in the
top end of the district
that's correct so we can certainly um
go back to tom wilson at the uni and
i'm actually meeting with one of his
colleagues tomorrow so i will
note that to to raise that thank you
council williams
hi um i'm just a bit concerned
about our assumptions and models and how
accurate
we've got all of our uh particularly on
the flooding side
considering just a while ago we had a
model
and all of a sudden it's been changed in
different areas and
and we but um what's the risks involved
in that if we get it wrong
in creating a um
scare you know for some lean owners and
we may have it wrong
um the accuracy of it because it hasn't
altered already
since um and we've you've already
suggested we've got assumptions out
there and um
is the modeling right before we actually
do a bit of scaring some of our
um
modeling is always based upon on
assumptions so there are a whole range
of assumptions that
that lead to the conclusions that that
modeling reaches
that's the case right now so we are
advising people right now about their
risk of flooding
uh and we would suggest that the
modeling that we have
while being far from perfect because
modeling never is
is a significant improvement on what we
have now i think
as we've indicated in the briefing there
was a number of changes
and improvements to the model that have
made that have brought it up to speed
in terms of the risk we
are in the role of pulling together the
best information we have
and i think we and the community are
entitled to rely on
that information we have and part of the
task we've been doing in advance of the
proposed district plan is getting a
third party review which was led by
trevor initially
in terms of the adequacy of our
underlying information that we were
relying on and that is indeed
why we have gone to the step of carrying
out this further work in terms of
reports and investigations and modelling
and so where we have identified
flaws that an independent third party
has indicated are
troublesome or potentially problematic
then we have taken steps to try and
close those gaps
i think we will always have the
situation where a flood may occur and it
may not occur in some areas and in
others
and there will always be challenges at
that time with people
questioning the basis of our underlying
information
i'd like to suggest that we have gone as
far as i
we think are uh prudent in terms of
expenditure of money
to get that modelling information as
accurate as we can
it is always a choice to go another
round and get further information etc
and try and improve these models
we wouldn't suggest that that was good
value for money to go any further with
trying to improve these
you are aware there are some um
engineers out there disputing some of
our modelling facts
and out there at the stage i think
another way to look at a councillor on
top of what donna said around the
modelling
is again i guess is how you use the
modelling going forward into future
years
and you may recall what a briefing at
the end of last
end of june andrew and andrew willis and
don
talked a little bit about the proposed
district plan policy response
and we're certainly coming back to the
committee at a date to be confirmed
later this month possibly the start of
next month or going to plan once that
date's confirmed
but that's around a floor level
certificate approach so that allows you
to look at the specific context of a
particular development or
at that time taking on board new
understanding either brought on board by
the applicant or
that has developed since the modeling
has occurred an example might be it
might be bad example that
the modeling has factored in all roads
and culverts as they exist today
tomorrow council or someone else may put
a new culvert in down the road which
changes the
flood modeling dynamic but the modeling
is
dated you know the day before the month
before or whenever it was
so by the floor level certificate or the
approach we're thinking you can pick up
on that new information
and apply it to the context of that you
know that that uh
development be it a house or or whatnot
one one more point on that i think we
would potentially suggest also that
presence of these models was going to
save our community
many many thousands of dollars because
in the absence of that modeling
we would be requiring everybody to get
their own model to
to establish the floodability of their
property at the moment with these models
uh each applicant has the choice of
either relying on the model that is put
in front of them and therefore
it is a relatively minimal cost or going
ahead and getting their own model done
because they disagree with the results
of our model
and we've just me personally have just
been involved in a recent incident
uh with an applicant uh in one of our
smaller rural towns where they did
disagree
and went and got a uh as a specific
model done
um in terms of their area and and that
was quite legitimate because our model
is a district-wide model
so it is a very large scale covers the
whole district
they picked out a small part of the
district and got some very specific
modeling done over their piece of land
and that showed far better results for
their particular
application and that was accepted by the
council as adequate proof
uh and they were allowed to then build
accordingly
if we didn't have an underlying model
that would be what we would require
every applicant to do who walked in our
door and asked for uh
asked for a development to occur
thank you councilman yes
um a couple of these communities are
quite well aware that there are risks
particularly waikoku
in okuku beach and kaipu because of all
the earthquake issues we've had
um and if i was a person in that area
i'd probably go to the map and say
where's my house
so if a person is looking at their
individual house
how would they then get someone to talk
to about what that actually means for
their existing property
that's not listed in the consultation
plan it might be a sign in comment
or treatment i i guess broadly with the
information that we've put together
we're looking to display that in a much
better way than we've done in the past
um i think uh at the 30th of june we put
up
did it work the um the technology
showing the
mapping portal which shows the different
layers of information available so the
liquefaction
layer sorry just to stop you it's not
about the technical information it's
about how they have a conversation with
someone
to what it means to us so first and
foremost you can go to that information
and then we'll make available how you
get in contact with staff
around that be it three water staff or
planning staff
so chris bacon for example uh operates a
system that works very well now
helping to advise probably in the
instance that don just gave an example
of now
around looking at his model on the end
of the phone on the end of the email
whatever the
system has in place to help that person
out likewise the same systems are in
place with
planning and that will be on the letter
going to households as well
uh so the letter coming up yes um there
certainly will be contact details around
that and
and i think else spelled that out and
one of the tables in the in the um
report there okay
as you were talking i was thinking about
some of the conversations we had
on this topic in drop-ins of recent
times as well
and you're right there are people who
will be anxious
and will become anxious as more
information becomes available and it's
it's a challenge i think in those in
those drop-in sessions
there is someone right there who can
talk to them
i would i think we need to draw a
distinction between information and
advice
and it's the dilemma that council is in
in so many ways
we will do our best to inform you of
what the situation is what the facts are
but if you're seeking advice from an
expert around
intentionally taking a um you know
deciding to put on a room or
build a new home etc at some point we do
need to say
you will need to engage your own advice
my observation is my colleagues are
pretty open and receptive to
as trevor highlighted with chris to
uh trying to do as much as we can um
to explain the
where we're coming from what the
information is what strengths of it is
are but at some point we will have to
say to people
you will need to engage your own expert
advice depending upon your
intentions just a supplementary question
to that um when we had the tsunami
modeling came out
civil defense held public meetings in
the evening that people could come
and talk together about what the maps
meant why aren't we taking that approach
in the evening so that
everybody can come to it and get that
collective questioning and knowledge in
this case
i think that's um and again i'm thinking
back to one of the
sessions that we had where the
the issues that were in the people's
forefront of their mind was around
what's the plan going to say and we're
not ready to
say now what the plan is going to say
but i do think those as part of the
engagement around the district plan we
want to do a whole lot more and you'll
want us to do a lot more than put a
notice in the paper
saying the district plan is available so
it's those kinds of
discussions that we will inevitably
having
right across the district around all
facets of the district plan but
particularly in the coastal communities
about
what natural hazards mean for them where
we're able to then point to the plan and
the plan provisions
and they are out there in the public
domain is alongside the information
to then say here's here's the way that
uh
we're responding to that and that has a
really
good discussion i have a little bit of
concern i'm sure like you do
that while it's important that we get
the best information out there
we will get questions on and as part of
this
round of engagement that we can't answer
right now
but we'll certainly be intentionally
doing that through the
engagement that goes with a notified
district plan in early 2021
just a little further they we we have in
here the two public drop-in sessions and
you've picked up that they're at four
o'clock at six o'clock
and they were intended to fit in around
the timing of the
of the community board meetings as per
their email we're very open to this
debate as it takes place after this
question time
to to give us guidance as to what would
be more appropriate
and give us feedback so those those were
initial suggestions from the staff
taking on board your points and very
happy to
receive your guidance on what you feel
is more appropriate i might just chip in
there as well if i can um i guess
there's some previous learnings um
around engaging with the community on
district plan and in particular district
plan hazards
um so i can think back over the last
five years there was the pc27
which was in 1617 district-wide
notifications i didn't go to letters and
letter boxes um with drop-in sessions in
the evenings um sort of
five to seven or seven five thirty seven
thirty something like that
twenty people uh more staff and
counsellors than
real people similar again last
last last year
cis apologies they are similarly uh last
year uh
with the hazards um let's talk process
about understanding people's appetite of
risk
it was a two-staged approach and four
evenings at four hours each
from three to seven so the late
afternoon into the early evening
20 people across the whole events as
well
so um i think there's some learnings
there about the time frames that
didn't really make a hell of a lot of
difference to that
where we certainly got some good we
where we get the most traction at least
the stage before we write to everybody's
part of the district plan
is working with the council and its
committee working with the community
boards
and with all those other stakeholders
and parties that are interested in the
topic of natural hazards
so late last year the second phase of
that
what's the plan let's talk um risk
discussion
had a invitee session where we got
most people this room had 30 people in
it and we were up here talking about it
so that certainly gave us best bang for
buck
so i guess those learnings have gone
into what is um in the paper
for you today uh i think
i think you can design that as we go
along we don't yes yes so
just just we can go on i mean the other
example was last night 6 30 in the
evening 70 people
if it's an issue people want to talk
about they'll turn up no matter what
time of day it is
now that's a general throwaway comment
if you like but um
i think we rather than design it over
the table i think
it's on board with the staff that they
will take that on board and have a look
at what those times will be
may i just add one person to your list
and that would be real estate agents
please
as a targeted response thank you thank
you council all right
thank you there is a question mr
to get there jess and i are building at
waikoku beach
two months ago we engaged in architect
costing three and a half thousand
dollars
about two three weeks ago we engaged a
building engineer he
said he could design the foundation and
assist with the bracing on the house
however
had we considered a deep geo he cost 4
so we went with davis ogilvy at four and
a half thousand dollars to assist him
to design the foundation for the build
out of waikoku
what's going to happen when that gets to
council are you going to say
that you're now going to have to engage
somebody
else to assist with the foundation
and it sounds a personal question but
it's it's not
i'm aware of three recent demolitions
out at waikoku beach
and one of them the demolition only
occurred a week and a half ago and i
noticed on sunday
that there's already the markings for
the build
so that's how quickly they're getting on
with uh with their
process so it's not it's personal but
it's not just
us so the process
on an application for either a a
building consent or a resource consent
will be that
a floor level certificate will be sought
as as adopted by the council in terms of
a process that floor level certificate
will advise you there will be a cost to
that certificate i can't record it as i
think it's 100
something dollars to obtain that
certificate
uh which will if you accept it
be no further cost it'll just be
advising you as to the level to put your
floor
where the cost may then come in is if
you feel that is excessive you
you dispute our particular number and
therefore there
possibly would be further advice to come
up with a different number
and we are expecting that could and and
possibly will happen
for for in particular multi-resident
developments where those sort of impacts
may be quite significant
um so we would be hopeful in in your
instance and i don't know any more
detail about the geo
technical conditions but in terms of
flooding that
should be a relatively simple process as
long as it was accepted between the
parties that the floor level that we
advised was was appropriate
so reading the report
and having attended the briefing and
what have you
does the elements that are scary but you
know if
given that and others are in the same
situation it's it's
scary based on your answer
we shouldn't be that scared we're it's
just wdc
trying to prepare for the future and
minimize risk is that is that
what you're saying it is what i'm saying
however where the dispute will come is
where people
have particular site information that
they believe points out that
our more general flooding assessment is
over
stating the case so i think that's where
you know we
we we maybe for instance you know we'll
have a floor height
and then we have a free board above that
and so by the time
we're finished it may well be we're
saying your house needs to be
seven or eight or 900 millimeters above
ground level or something like that
which is not insignificant cost to add
to a house
and so while yes it is with the right
goals and objectives that we're doing
this it will
in certain places in the district have a
real implication
on the cost of building uh and that's
where we do need to be
sure that both the underlying modeling
is as good as we can get it
but also then those assumptions we're
making about what happens next
to come up with that floor level are
also as good as we can make it and that
is where you will be
receiving and discussing the floor level
practice certificate
which is where you will get to discuss
what is it we're doing about that floor
level to turn it into
ah sorry what is that we're doing about
that flood level
to turn it into a floor level and that's
the next
part of the discussion which is not yet
in front of you but will be in front of
you for you to think about
just remind councillors too that we we
are talking about going to consultation
before we get to to making decisions on
this so
you know it will come back um to us for
decisions once the consultation has
taken place
not so much the natural natural hazards
information
we should be really clear so this is the
hazards information just go out and
here it is community then it's about
what we do with that which is
just things will come back to us is what
i'm saying yeah
um just just going back to a
couple things that just popped out to me
from robbie's impulse questions um i
just wanted to just just clarify so don
are you saying that an individual if
they
don't like what's been put on their limb
or
um where their land sits in a hazard
model or whatnot that they can actually
go and they can either choose to accept
our modeling or they can go and get
their own and then submit that to you
so they've got a choice of either saying
okay we'll take years that you've
already done or
get independent advice yeah yes that is
correct and to get to use the example
before it was in a
in a development and theft and in our
modeling showed a significant breakout
from the local stream
would occur and send reasonable amounts
of water through this particular
development
so they undertook to get
a model of course at a reasonably
significant cost to them so i'm not
suggesting this is an easy path but they
had
20 or 30 houses that were going to be
affected by this development
and so they chose to get us their own
flooding report and it predicted that
that flooding would
would not emerge from that stream in the
same manner
and it significantly changed what needed
to happen on their site
we of course peer reviewed their report
we didn't just accept it as
a given and the peer reviewer and the
modeler worked together and
and ended up accepting uh an alternative
to what we had originally proposed for
our flood modelling
so what you're saying then is that if
somebody is feeling aggrieved by
some aspect of this that they can
actually go
and provide an alternative um it's an
alternative option for those people
question you can but i'm not belittling
there is a cost involved in that that
that is
a real uh probably a barrier for most
people
that may avoid them from doing that
but there's that option thank you
council williams yeah follow up from
council brian's situation
i'm a wee bit concerned what would
happen
are we developing a system where if
somebody wants to
go through at a great cost to get a
floor level that done
300 meters from the ground level
uh three 300 millimeters from ground
level and
um and all of a sudden the neighbor that
doesn't want to spend that
amount of money so they'll just accept
the council one
and also this might be two meters
sticking out of the ground
two meters and that has been put by one
particular property area on our flood
modeling
could we be creating a staircase of
houses at different levels that
would be unsightly um down a street
frontage for example
by doing it this way
i think where somebody had developed
information upon a
particular property that the council
accepted
was fair and reasonable for that
property then we would be using that
information to assist the neighbours
property as well
so we certainly and as i acknowledge
that our
our model is a district-wide model so it
is at a
let's call it a course level and if
somebody came in and said well
here's flooding about my particular
property and it showed that 300
millimeters above ground was in fact the
appropriate one
it went through the appropriate checks
and was accepted
then we would not then we would not
ignore that information
when the neighbor walked in the door and
said i'm actually going to build
i'm not saying we would automatically
accept it on the neighbourings property
because there may be a number of issues
which differentiated the neighbor from
there
but all i am saying is we would continue
to build our body of knowledge on
whatever
had happened in the past to advise what
we were then going to advise people in
the future
perhaps um just further to that probably
the scenario more likely is in an
established urban area where a house is
demolished and then rebuilt and the new
floor level applies
you could have existing houses that are
substantial
have a substantially lower you know
perhaps up to a meter
or so and kyopoi i think is some of the
pictures that we've seen where the where
the floor level for a new dwelling
as a replacement could be substantially
higher than those
adjacent to it and that will look odd in
a community
no doubt and we'll try create a number
of
um neighbor storm water issues that will
need to be carefully managed as that
as those diff height differentials are
uh are achieved and it depends whether
it's the floor level going up a meter
and you've got
a number of steps or if somebody then
tries to raise the adjacent
you know all of their proper their land
around it so they don't look like
they're a meter out of the ground
um they will create they will create
challenges
as areas redevelop that are currently
below the
recommended floor level heights and
that's something we're going to have to
continue to work on and is probably
going to be one of the bigger community
challenges i suspect
and that particular issue raised
by the chief executive is one of the
matters that will be debated by you in
terms of the policy response and that is
how do we
deal with existing or
well infill areas in existing
residential areas so there will
be potentially a specific
district plan response to that that
you will have the opportunity to discuss
before it gets adopted
and just in briefings around townships
such as kaiapoi where there's the option
to mitigate not just a void
there's we'll talk more later it's
around existing use rights in any
extensions to houses and the choice of
rebuilding what you had or taking the
option of building up higher
then i guess another third component is
certainly the displacement on neighbours
and
managing that and a fourth is then
around what would normally
be permissible on a section in terms of
could you build a two-story house on
that section so how does a house that's
one story built up slightly more
implicate that what is the overall
height of the building and what is the
overall height of the building
relative to boundaries in terms of you
know shading and overlooking and those
types of matters so there's all sort of
there's a strategy of as to how you can
think about these things we'll talk more
later on those
i'm prepared to move from the chair just
just adding
c in the consultation
that targeted uh consultation
to and i don't want to say building
industry there's probably a bit much
better name in there as
real estate industry to to appropriate
industries
relating to this um so just adding that
into
c do we have a second second at the
council barnett
right um look this has to go out we have
this information
it would be very irresponsible of us not
to share this information
i've had my doubts with the modeling
right the way through i think this is
the third change in the last
last couple of three terms that i've
been here
and as we add in more mitigations that
our district takes the better that it
gets
i think the first iteration that i saw
was some years ago which was given to us
from the regional council that never
even had the riverbanks in it
and the questions around the volume of
water they were talking about wouldn't
even fit through the ashley
gorge so we've made significant
improvements
um on this modelling as we go through
and i think
both don and and trevor are absolutely
right you have to have
a baseline in which to work off we may
not agree with
with it totally but that is that is a
personal thing the modeling is the
modelling
and it continues to be a moving feast
and it will continue to be a moving
feast as mitigation
becomes um becomes available
as to the floor levels uh uh i just
wanted to talk to the
um trevor's last point and i absolutely
agree with them
that if you were doing an in-field
situation
someone could build a two-story house
next door to you someone could build a
single-story
house next door to you it could be a
tiny home
the level of that will not make any
difference as long as you meet the rest
of the rules around the
around the district plan such as
floodplains and and
shadowing on houses and all of those
things that that happen
i live in a street now where the corner
houses is an old-fashioned two-story
house which is actually the size of a
three-story house of today
and that looks right into my backyard my
house is built at 800
off the ground and i have three steps in
which to get into my place the place
next door to me
which is only the year of the earthquake
is built on the ground i already live in
that situation you're talking about
but all they met all the other rules of
the district plan to build where they
are it makes
not one scrap of difference to the fact
of
of uh of the floor levels it could be at
1.5 if someone decides to do that next
door to me then
that's as long as they meet the rules
that aren't going to shadow my house or
and i accept the runoff of um of
stormwater i accept that but that's part
of mitigation and building and what
you're allowed to do and what you're not
allowed to do
i think that it actually some people see
it as an eyesore i don't i actually
think that it
adds variety and you don't end up with a
whole heap of houses that look the same
along one stretch of road so i think
it's actually quite helpful
myself um i do know that in kaipoy
my the builder who works for me he had
to build his place up to
1200 somehow by the time he got to the
end of it he was only at 300
but it added something like about a
hundred thousand dollars to his build
and that's the reality of of where we're
at the costs of this in certain areas is
going to be massive
and what worries me around that is
particularly an infill
that people won't build and we will end
up with empty sections
within people's uh within the
communities
and start to break those communities
down over time
we also have to put it into perspective
about when and why and how these things
will happen so
um we have to do it there is no choice
um it needs to be done and we have to
stop mucking around
deciding on when why and how and get on
and do it
and that's what this does so i hope that
you will support it
councilman yes i'm definitely going to
support this report it's absolutely
necessary that we do this
and we've got this information and it is
necessary for it to be public
and i'm very pleased that there is a way
that people can interact with it and
actually see
exactly where they are and what's
happening um it has to go on limbs as
soon as we have this information
available it has to be able to be tagged
to the properties affected
um the the only issue i have a concern
with is
that we talk about floor levels and
we're talking about rules going forward
and we have to do that for the district
plan we have to look at what's the most
sense
but my concern is existing properties
and
these are actually people's lives and
essence and often their only investment
for retirement
um and it may well it's potentially
when people look at limbs it can affect
property value and sales
and that's the feedback i'm getting from
real estate agents
even with some a recent application
that's out there at the moment it's
already affecting house sales in the
area of renewal
so this map going out is just extra
information it's another layer of
information that may
give people pause to think what happens
and the word flooding
as soon as you mention flooding in
kaiapoi in waikoku beach
it's a very hot topic it always has been
and i'm thinking of the psychosocial
impact of that
people are going to be concerned they're
going to want to ask questions
um and what we've seen when we've had
community consultations is if we
initiate it as the councils they come
along to a meeting
we don't get many people but if the
community initiate it
the drainage meeting why cook it filled
waikoku beach hall there were 60 plus
people there
because they were concerned about an
issue they had questions
they organized the meeting and we sent
stuff to it
now that's how i say we should be doing
this
the evening meetings in conjunction with
a local group that's got the context to
get the people there
and that's where you actually can be the
most successful
floor levels absolutely have to be done
but what i'm concerned about is just
talking to people making sure they
understand
that often the fear is worse than the
reality what will actually happen
and the type length of time we're
talking that gives us time to adapt and
mitigate going forward
is the actual fear of something
happening is often worse than what's
actually the reality of it happening
and that's where we need to have these
one-on-one conversations and these
community consul
uh conversations with those particularly
affected groups of waikoku beach
and kaiapoi as was done during the
earthquakes and other natural disasters
like the tsunami
i will be supporting this but i have got
concerns about
um they're not making land anymore
and we've already had an example here of
luckily um
the developer got his own engineers and
overturned the what the council had
plainly wrong
in their modeling um i would like to see
parcels of land get um overshadowed and
foreseen because they think
it's going to be a flood plain when
actually it's not going to be a flood
plain so
i think we've got to be pretty accurate
and they're modeling before we actually
designate places
that are going to be underwater because
um lane's not getting
any cheaper and we're not making land
anymore
we've just had climate change we're
actually losing land at the moment so
we don't want to be losing more land
than um what we need to so we've got to
be pretty accurate
on our modeling before we actually turn
around and see if that section is going
to be um
flood prone under water when it possibly
may not be
and as council barnett's going to just
said
it can develop devalue somebody's
family's inheritance they've had for 30
40 years
that long term the grandchildren are
going to build on that bit of land and
all of a sudden they find they can't
build on it because
it's never been wet before but all of a
sudden it's sitting in a situation where
it could be underwater
so i think we just got to be very
careful that we get our modelling
right and know exactly and we've just
had
well i thought it was the second time
but obviously the third time we've had
her modeling wrong
and altered so um is there going to be a
fourth time
probably there is so we need to be a bit
more accurate um
with what we're doing um we could say
it's
the risks are quite bad for the
property owners that and i know several
property owners
um that they've got property that they
wanted to build on and all of a sudden
they found out the cost of building on
this particular
properties they've got is too great and
all of a sudden they've got property
they can't do anything with at the
moment except pay rates on it so
we'd be very careful on the way we go
about it um
yeah you know just lane's getting scarce
now and we um
we don't want a development of nothing
in an area of um um
places where we could be building and um
quite comfortably building on as well
thank you council williams council
blackie
just a couple of comments um reiterating
what i said on the previous item on the
agenda
plea please ask aleister to be concise
with what goes out there
our people at the coastal area because
this this sort of thing tends to affect
them more than pros
arguably more than anywhere else we're
getting consultation fatigue down there
by their own admission they've had five
years of being consulted
and they need they okay this has to go
there no argument about that
but it needs to be brief and it needs to
be focused and almost a pricey
um you know if you'll excuse the plan
you flood the market
with information you'll you'll overwhelm
them they'll they'll just
back away and all you're doing is
scaremongering
and and they're pushing up their anxiety
factors without actually
getting them to engage with the
information they need and the other
thing to mention just remember too the
kapiti coast
council incident a few years ago when
kirsten and others have mentioned this
has got to go on the limbs just remember
that council put natural hazard
coastal stuff on the limb everybody with
a house on the coast saying
you are living in a risk area and they
took the wealthy
residents took the council to court and
won in the high court and had the
council remove that
which to everyone to my amazement anyway
because i thought it was actually common
sense
but they won in case and made the
council remove that information from the
limb so we've got to be just a bit
careful about what we put on the limb
council barack thank you and on
our induction tour in 1998 gareth james
was in charge of engineering utilities
and roading back in those days
and he stopped the bus on icookie beach
road next to the
lagoon and said
this is flooded before showed us
pictures of flooding
which extended right down through
pegasus all the way to the
waimakariri river and he said it will
flood again
it hasn't yet but it will i've got
absolutely no doubt in my mind that it
will
which is why obviously i'm going to
support those but
as i mentioned in my when i ask those
questions
it is pretty scary because you know i'm
looking at a foundation
which i thought was going to be perhaps
eighty thousand ninety thousand
and i'm looking at it probably another
fifty eighty thousand
uh on the foundation uh depending on
what that floor level turns out to be
and i don't know
because i haven't got the dgo pack that
was only done yesterday
but these are some of the questions that
you know i would anticipate staff are
going to be asked
in this in this process and
yeah but obviously it's got to be you
know the other side is none of us want
to put a
beautiful house only to have the
blooming thing flooded and wrecking
televisions and all the rest of the
carry-on so
um it's got to be done i've got no
issues with that but it's got to be done
delicately
council reading uh thank you mr deputy
mayor
um councillor blackie has raised the
issue
that i was going to mention about the
importance of getting the information
correct on limbs um i think that's
crucial this whole topic is actually
very crucial to the district
and as council blackie said on the
eastern
area in particular
just commenting on what councillor
williams said
the coastline is actually accreting and
growing so we are making
more land in our district only in the
outer district
and the third thing i'd like to comment
on is the engagement and communications
um i quite like the comments and
counselor barnett's email
about going to where the people are and
i think people will want to know about
their particular property
and you need to have a laptop or a map
or some way of showing it to them
and um i mean if we do it um i think
they'll come
we saw last evening in kaiapoi although
it was a public
initiated meeting um people did turn out
and it was a really good meeting and
well conducted so thank you to the staff
who were there last night as well
so i think this is very important and
i'm more than happy to support it but i
do have reservations about
what information goes on limbs and how
it is presented
thank you thank you
council award thank you i just um have
listened to everyone and
um i will be supporting this but i think
we also must remember that
in the last few years there's been a
tremendous amount of
flood mitigation happening and um
i think the situation has improved
greatly um
throughout the district and it's it's
forever evolving and changing
and so we we must be really careful that
we don't become too scaremongering
um we need to be honest but um we need
to
understand that we're always
trying to improve the flood mitigation
and our district
and improving um the risk
so i just that's all i'd like to say
thank you
thank you just know the first speakers
in my right of reply just a couple of
things really just to
reiterate that when we look at the
modeling that was there kype was
actually improved
by plenty if you like in the latest
flood modelling so
you know that's to be taken on board and
if that continues then
you know they'll be the highest place in
the district by the time we get to
the year 3000 um
if that continues but um
i'd just like to point that out um the
other one that i i it's about accuracy
and and where doubt comes from within
our
within our room within our own district
and people think of their lifetime when
they think about
um this modeling and how it works you
know um
i can remember distinctly duck shooting
down line side road
in my mind off the paddocks there with
the the water
above the um uh the fence line
not one drop of car of water in kaiapoi
after the rainfall
not one not one flood yet our modelling
says will be a meter underwater
so they are the sorts of arguments which
joe bloggs is going to bring to us
when they wish to build or in this
consultation
because we need to make sure that we
have the right information that it is
correct
and if we can explain those situations
and why they've why there
was nothing then and there will be now
then that's fine but if you can't
then quite honestly expect some um
expect some criticism from them because
as we know they do work on their
lifetime as opposed to
what has gone uh before that
um i remember
back in my younger days i was we were
originally going to
shift westport and um god knows why
um yeah but um we got on our limbs
was given to us by the solicitor um
it was a flood that had happened there
70 years beforehand
and has to my knowledge never happened
again
um and then and i've lived in my home
now for 36 years so put that on top of
that it's over 100 years since that
flood has actually hit westport so
we did what every other um person who
buys a home did
well that was 70 years ago go give a
damn i'll i'll be fine
so the other sorts of things that we
need to to take into account that
it will as council brian said it will
happen at some stage
and and at some time we don't know when
it will be but
um that information that's on limbs we
want to make sure that it's updated as
often as we can
so that you don't get into that
situation when it's when it is given to
people
that they actually take notice that it's
like latest information that's on there
so um look i i welcome this consultation
i i accept all the
um uh ideas put forward for
for doing the conf consultation with the
right people at the right time in the
right place
um our staff try to do that at the all
the time so i think that
um that will be taken on board and we
will we will get the best out of it so i
urge you
all to support that and although you
think you just about all said you are
supporting it so
we'll wait for the eyes so i'll put that
all those in favor
against kerry thank you
right item 8.4
which is uh mr young again where are you
mr
obviously isn't it
pages four three two four five
four
thank you uh mr deputy mayor
uh i've invited uh i've invited libby up
to sit with me i'm not sure if many of
you have met libby hurley but she works
in our
area and libby will be assisting me pull
together the
monthly report from now on uh in terms
of the
the monthly spreadsheet that we pull
together we put it in front of you of
course on a quarterly basis
but we actually pull it together and
discuss it internally on a monthly basis
so i thought it was useful for
uh libby to be part of this conversation
as well because she'll be
quite critical in terms of ensuring you
get the right information in front of
you
the purpose of this report i think is to
take into account some of the
discussions that were had
last year when there was quite a lot of
discussion and interest in improving
our performance
in in terms of the annual
report or performance against achieving
the annual budget
and i think we all recognize that were
two or three matters or a number of
matters
that affected our ability to uh to hit a
target
that you would be or hit an amount that
you would be more comfortable with
and some of those were certainly
performance delivery and i think you've
heard
mr cleary mention on a number of
occasions various
improvements we're making to our systems
to try and improve our performance
but some of them also were reporting
matters
and noting i guess the
the clunkiness or the um the coarseness
of the method in which we were reporting
to you
one of the ideas that was floated and i
can't remember was whether it was by us
to you or by you to us
was to come back with a method
of taking into account
those particular projects which the
council had less control
over we attempted to do that in a couple
of the quarterly reports last year but
it was really just
by no more than really a narrative what
we have done
now uh is with the help of
the minute minister of finance the
manager of finance
is to uh to pull together a couple of
extra columns which we're asking our
project managers
to populate and they talk about the
planned
likelihood of completion and then during
the year
we will update that with the predicted
likelihood of completion
now what we wanted to do by ensuring
this was
report was in front of you before the
year started
was to give you confidence
that we were
setting our sights on a fair and
equitable basis at the start of the year
not with a little bit of hindsight as
as month one and two and three had gone
by and we were reporting to you
in quarter one and we could see that all
we're already struggling let's
uh let's let's set a slightly lower bar
so
the reason for getting this in front of
you now is to ensure that we're
all on exactly the same wavelength at
the start of the year
about what it is we're trying to achieve
and get your acceptance of that
the second thing i'd note is that we
have been very strict on ourselves
in terms of the definition of council
control
and so it may have surprised you as it
did surprise me how many
how fewer projects actually are affected
when we brought this
method into play we had thought it would
be more
but the fact that there is land purchase
to be obtained or there are consents to
be obtained or as there is
consultation with nzta to occur has
not allowed us to say anything less than
we have kept all of those in the council
controlled
even though there are potentially quite
significant issues that we need to work
through
in order to achieve our goal and so we
have i hope you'll see
by by putting this information in front
of you i hope you will see that we have
tried to maintain a very high level of
discipline with regard to this but what
it has done
is it has slept allowed us to select a
slightly lower bar
not in terms of the budget that will
always remain our goal but in terms of
our predicted
well our planned likely expenditure at
the end of the year
what we have allowed to happen
is that we will probably be altering the
predicted
likelihood of expenditure even on the
hundred percent ones once the year gets
underway
and that will be another reporting tool
which we will report back
to you during the year where we start to
you know at the end of the first quarter
if we're starting to say well actually
we think it is less likely
we will complete such and such job we
would be
signaling that to you and you would see
an early indication
of what then we were signaling to you
and be able to give us feedback
accordingly
but i have not much more else to
to provide in terms of an update on this
i'm hoping it's relatively
self-explanatory
what i or one last thing i would note is
that
this this numbering system doesn't
make a lot of sense if you read it line
by line because
often these particular jobs are either
going to get a hundred percent done or
they're going to get zero percent done
and we're put in 50 percent or 75 we're
never going to
spend 75 percent of it we'll either
spend 100 or zero
but what that does do is when you
average it up over ten or fifteen
projects
is it allows the summing of that to be a
more accurate reflection of what is
likely to happen
but i'm happy to take any questions i
think you don't that
libby do you have anything to add
and here you are are there any questions
whether donald will be
uh counselor stuart is it slightly um
to the left field well perhaps not um
i remember when um the standard pools
come
to evaluate this council its ability to
do
the program within um and spend the
capital
um budget within the 12 months it is a
is an assessment that they do make and
they've been critical
of this council in the past so do you
actually see
this measure as assisting with our
standard and pools rating as a
as a apart from you know
it looks very attractive to um us here
that we will be
arguably on you will be on board
far more than we have in the past but
does it actually have that other
benefit no yes yeah
maybe
[Laughter]
look uh anything which demonstrates
better better
um management over our capital program
should be recognized and hopefully
acknowledged by standard and poor's
um like you um they will probably say
the proof's more in the pudding
um so let's see what the results are
over a period of time will
more likely be their response but
if that's helping us get to a better
place or at least
when we're not in a better place we're
at least in a better informed place
which is uh
where libya and dada they're not
responsible for they're not accountable
for delivery of the program that
they're there to help us understand um
who you should hold accountable and to
what extent
and that's me and our leadership
thank you right we have a recommendation
on the table
uh moved account oh you have a question
counsel whatevs
to counsel to um is it common for the
council to be making
uh development contributions of a
million dollars um
for private um enterprise
so they they are they they that's the
sum total of projects and they're
usually ones where
um we'll do you know oxford road i
suppose would be one out here where
we've
where there'll be upgrades occurring and
some will
be cost will be borne by the developer
but
there is actually an improvement that
the ratepayers or residents should
share so so that fund is
funding that share of works when a when
a development occurs
which is you know assessed on a fair and
equitable basis so it's usually other
improvements that are occurring at the
same time as a developer
as making a contribution or sometimes it
will be
where a developer puts in a storm or a
pond
and we and it'll be bigger uh
than needed or because it's providing
capacity to deal with other
residential um issues that aren't the
developers responsibilities so
it's those sort of projects that tend to
get picked up in there
so in that particular instance council
wins and i'm sorry i don't i didn't
print off all of those detailed pages
but
there is a million dollars in there and
i think it will probably pentecost
is it dependent across road stormwater
management area you're referring to
that is a significant cost which is the
council's benefit
that we are obtaining on behalf of a
whole range of
other users who will benefit from that
stormwater management area that they are
building
i don't know if you've got anything
further there jerry you know i think
yeah just to clarify with jim
um does that mean our development
contributions we're getting
aren't great enough and or
if we're expanding something for future
development
that will um a development contribution
will come off of that million dollars
we'll put aside
later on yeah so um if if the
cost that we're bearing now is because
of other growth
that is to be incurred then that will go
to a dc
somewhere else in our in our calculation
for example if it's been across road
storm water uh management basin
i think there are other properties there
there are three beneficiaries i think of
that
that i that i'm aware of um there is
existing ratepayers there are
existing developers and their future
developers so the future developers
share of that would be ring fenced and
then
recovered through a development
contribution at a later stage
and in some instance they are dc's that
we've
had in the bank for quite some time as
people have paid for them in the past
and now the infrastructure works to
mitigate their effect of actually being
there is only just being built so we've
taken those dc's from
other developers knowing that this work
is coming along
and then contributing their share to
that work so we have basically played
banker
that can also happen so eventually
you'll be cost neutral then so it's
actually um
not going to cost the council anything
because the other part of my question
was are our development contributions
enough
to cover this type of thing um
so uh two-part question there
yes except for that share that is a fair
rate payer share so
you know when we upgrade foot paths for
example on a new
and connect then we'll pay a we may wall
street light and then we'll pay a share
there so that will be a rate payer
for the balance that is deemed to go to
a develop
uh for development contribution over
time the intent is for that to be
cost neutral all those don says we do
play banker in the meantime
there is uh in terms of other dc's
enough
um we've had no developers coming to us
in recent times saying your dc's are too
low
quite the reverse in fact
[Laughter]
we're conscious when we're sitting dc's
you
we have to be very alert to what is fair
and reasonable from a developer's point
of view and from a ratepayers point of
view and it's quite a hard balance
sometimes to find but i i we
put quite a lot of attention to that and
the dc's and you can see that
some councils have just one dc for say
sewer
and that's it and it doesn't matter
where in the district a new
a new property will get a sewer dc
whereas in
waimakariri we've thought about it quite
a lot if you're in west rangiora you'll
get a west
west rangiora dc
um we haven't played the powerball
um if we're thanks jared
if we're if you're in west rangiora
you'll get a west range or a dc you'll
get a
rangi or a trunk main upgrade dc
and you'll get an ocean out for dc so
we've thought about each part of our
district as to who are the beneficiaries
of work and who should fund that
you moving oh question
i admit to being quite surprised with
the the comment you made about most of
them being under council control
um initially for those ones that we have
some risks with nzta decisions or with
legal decisions or consent decisions
will you be looking more closely at
those to try and perhaps
spread some of that expenditure into the
following financial year where there is
that risk
so a really good comment um i think we
recognize that our ability to
to deliver a higher percentage of our
capital works program has
has a number of actions that need to
take place and one of those is certainly
being more
realistic and spreading works over
multiple years to ensure that we
allow that time so when we can see it
has all of these impediments in it
we should only be then coming to you and
asking for enough money for a realistic
in year one uh the other one which i
think the council
it is really good to give the council a
little bit of an update on this year
because i think the whole of the
utilities and roading should be very
proud about the
state we are in come the end of july
for the coming year compared to any
other year including the 10 i was in
here before
we are well advanced with defining scope
getting that scope agreed with pdu who
are going to deliver
and getting pdu underway with delivering
those works i think we're in the best
state we've ever been
now i'm probably going to oversell my
case a little bit here and maybe regret
this in a year
but i am far more hopeful this year that
we are in a really positive state to
deliver our
program this year which we needed to be
and we accept that
not very much to say but i'm really
really pleased this report has come to
us
it helps us keep a much more realistic
view on what our capital expenditure is
going forward
i i don't think it will help us very
much with
standard poor's however um i think it's
been quite unfair how sometimes
um we look at it and say 73 that's
terrible couldn't you guys have done
better
but actually you've actually had a lot
of external matters that have impacted
on that result and this will give us a
much more genuine
um target for the end of the year and it
gives us an idea going forward and
it's always hard do you pull the money
forward do you leave it out and and we
totally understand that with
with multi-year projects um but it is
really good to see the improvements in
the space
and i want to congratulate you don and
all the team who've worked on this
project because i really
am seeing some light at the end of the
tunnel on this issue and looking forward
to the next report
ecmo council of council bonanza comments
good report
it'll be done i'll put that all those in
favor against
carried all right i'm going to take 10
10 minutes 10 minute break as you can
tell the jug's on cue
so we'll have a 10 minute break and come
back
and then and then we will come back
um yep and then we'll have a further
break
just before we go into public excluded
for uh
for that other item
um
all right okay welcome back
we'll get underway um
item 8.5 which is uh
rob and rob pages four
five five two four eight two
welcome rob and rob
all right good afternoon um councillors
um
this report uh asks or sets out the
findings from a recent seismic strength
investigation
and seeks approval for additional budget
and an accelerated procurement process
to enable the project to be delivered
council will be aware of the several
iterations and changes to the project
of the refurbishment of the service
centre over recent years
the most recent change being in response
to the financial pressures
created by the pandemic which resulted
in a reduced scope and budget
to 1.5 million as part of the design
process
for this revised scope routine
structural reviews identified a change
in
engineering guidance which meant that
the assessed strength of the western
first
floor uh is now assessed at 40 of the
new building standard
although not a legal or health and
safety issue as such
um in in the near future
this reduced the seismic performance and
in consideration to the reasonable
concerns of staff and
and others we have sought to limit
access to this area until it is
strengthened
pal finnick consultants have advised
that the repair
of the floor is best achieved through
the installation of a carbon fiber
polymer mat along with some other
structural ties to the chambers
area in light of these additional costs
as well as recent further announcements
in relation to three waters
we have reviewed the assumptions sitting
behind the business case
and we consider that these assumptions
still remain valid as potential for
relocation of the three waters
was accounted for in the scenarios
tested earlier
the option to refurbish and extend the
existing building remains significantly
less expensive
than the alternative option of moving to
a different location
a condition assessment of the heating
and ventilation system along with the
repair costs for the seismic upgrade
has led to the project steering group
recommending to increase the budget
for the project by 1 million to a total
of 2.5 million
this includes an increase in contingency
to provide greater confidence
that any further unforeseen issues are
able to be covered by the budget
just like to cover off on the
accelerated procurement process
council will be aware that
staff are now working again from home or
in less than ideal work spaces in other
council buildings
as such the project steering group
recommended an accelerated procurement
process
to get contractors on board as early as
possible without losing a comparative
process
in relation to price but also giving
some preference to local suppliers
as per the procurement policy this is
outside
of our normal procurement policy
guidelines
but council can deviate from this in
exceptional circumstances
and ensure that the organization can
continue to deliver services to the
community
the proposed procurement approach is
covered in the following main points
the main contractor we're looking
for tenders for four main con from four
main contractors
that are currently on the new trades
panel um that has been independently
established
more recently uh the seismic contractor
tends to sort from two specialist
contractors recommended by the
structural engineer for this work
and the heating and ventilation and air
conditioning tenders are sought from
five contractors with two local
suppliers identified
again based on recommendations from our
services engineer
the rationale for the deviation from the
policy is an
increased pace to limit the time over
which staff are in less than ideal
working conditions
use of a pre-qualified trades panel
means that tenders have already been
through a robust and
comparative process and are of an
appropriate quality
the ability to procure local suppliers
where possible to enhance the economic
recovery of the district
is a part of the tendering process
noting that waiting is given to the main
contractor
who uses local suppliers
the selection of specialist contractors
who are proven to be able to deliver the
work
are noted um on the recommendation of
our professional advisors
and finally the seeking of tenders from
a short list ensures
uh that there is a price tension and the
price to ensure that the council
is able to obtain value for money
in short the project steering group
consider that these are compelling
reasons for the accelerated procurement
approach
to this project and
with that i'll open it up to questions
rob do you have anything to add to you
yes i almost got confused then no no
no further to add that's uh that's
pretty much a summary of where where
the two rods have got to so thanks for
that
council redmond
ah thank you mr deputy mayor um on page
462 of diligent the key risks
associated with the project are listed
are these the risks during the
refurbishment process
or risks at conclusion of the project
i was concerned with the comments
relating to staff
and disruption and i'm hoping it's
during
the refurbishment period before they go
back
to their space can you clarify that
please
uh yeah you're correct the the um
the third uh risks that we're talking
about there
uh delay and delay in project milestone
leading to a further disruption to staff
that is during the construction process
that's right
and teams do not adapt well to new
environment is that the temporary
environment or the new environment at
conclusion
that actually refers to the new
environment although it also perhaps
also relates to the current or and
temporary environment as well
what very aware of this is still a
change process so
whether it's a good change or a bad
change it still has a disruptive effect
so we're very aware of that as we work
through this
right thank you my second question is by
doing both works the seismic
strengthening
and the refurbishment at the same time
um
two things are we saving money by doing
it and if so how much
and b is it creating additional stress
for staff with further and extended
disruption
so it's almost essential to do the
seismic strengthening at the same time
as the refurbishment
because we have to clear the
area of the internal walls strip the
carpet
and other works before we do the seismic
strengthening and that of course is what
we do anyway for the refurbishment
and it would be quicker as a result
in terms of cost savings it's always
difficult to exactly
calculate that but generally this sort
of thing i would say probably in terms
of 10 or 15
of that establishment cost being able to
be i combine the two contracts together
council award thank you
just a question is there any likelihood
that they might find further seismic
faults
in the in the structures or the floors
once they
they take up the flooring uh and another
question
the hvac upgrade has that needed to be
upgraded through
um because of the present conditions i
heard a whisper that that was more
faulty than they originally thought
so this is a refurbishment of an older
building
so there is always the possibility that
there
we will uncover defects or other issues
um we've all renovated houses and done
things like that you know it's the same
thing we
we there always the possibility of
finding that we've done so far uh work
to try and minimize that risk
but i think that is also why we've
suggested a greater contingency that we
might
normally on a project at this stage of
maturity
to allow for those sort of unforeseen
matters arising
so we shouldn't be naive that we may
find that we won't find anything
but certainly we're doing our best to
make sure that if we do we've got enough
money to cover it
in terms of your second question in
terms of the h fact
the condition assessment that we've done
at the the mechanical plant is in
reasonable condition but it's old
and there are myriad of issues that that
that it brings
and so there is some risk
that uh we m if
we did us a smaller level of replacement
and upgrade that we may not be able to
meet the performance requirements that
would be reasonable for an office
probably if i can just add to that
somewhat
the the history of this project goes
back a number of years
and at least three or four years ago we
identified that we were having
struggling in terms of the performance
of the existing system
and and that in
some areas parts were difficult to
obtain all of those things
as we've gone on get harder and harder
to keep on top of
and so yes we are experiencing some
ongoing failures and challenges
here today to keep it working so that's
getting now to
more of a critical point where those
parts of the building in particular that
are
under a managed environment that is a
building management system
controlled environment um are are
actually
very difficult to to keep working
properly and certainly they are not
efficient and there are significant
other impacts in terms of
sustainability and those sorts of things
so
that it is age and as a result of that
age condition
a few questions i'm happy to move do we
have a second
second council of duty
thank you um for me this is a a
no-brainer
that i think um rob
left um it describes it well i mean it's
it's an old villa sitting in a new
street and um
you know when you lift the floorboards
the choices are gone
and that can happen and we shouldn't be
and i even think that that may not
happen
hopefully it won't sometimes it's made
out of good material and that
uh that doesn't happen so let's hope
that that's the case
this is something that money won't be
wasted we need to we need to do this to
make sure
the health and so that we cover off the
health and safety of our staff i think
just about just about every councillor
around here
um over the period of time that we've
been discussing this has talked about
the appalling conditions
that staff have found themselves in
through no fault of their own and
certainly
not really through the fault of the
council through the situation that the
building has evolved
into with the amount of number of people
in which we've which we've done that we
have to put a stop sign
at the end of that and we have to fix
what we can for now
and move on as quickly as we can to make
sure that the staff have as little as
disruption as they
can and get the best out of something
that we have
to then eventually move to another
discussion down the track about
where we go what we do from there but
this this in my view
is a it just has to happen to make sure
that everybody is
in the in the best space that they can
be in for this organisation to move
forward
in the way that it always has we've
always been leaders as far as
councils go in in what we do in our
district it should be no different for
our staff we should lead
and make sure that they are in
conditions that are
perfectly acceptable for them to work in
so i think that this is something that
we
we absolutely have to do and that we
need to do
absolutely adequately to make sure that
we
are in front of it councillor duty
okay thank you you've just um
stolen some of my things i was going to
say but but i what i really
would like to say is thank you very much
robs and rob um
for what um you have put together here
and
i know we really very much appreciate um
the work and effort that you've put
towards us and
also considering our staff trying to
do what's best for them as well and i'd
just like to do a big thanks to the
staff
that have had to move out and the
conditions that they're
working in that some of them are not
particularly great because they're
cramped in but i just like to say big
thank you very much them
because for putting up was what has to
be done
for the greater good of us all any
further speakers
council millions um just just
in my travels i um in the last
you know little while i was speaking to
one person that said that they
used to work at a building in town
beautiful new flash
modern left that to come and work for us
and another person in a similar
situation
also said that and i quote
this is the worst building i've ever
worked in but they still want to work
for the ymca duty district council
our staff are our biggest asset
they are the reason why we have two
back-to-back aaa ratings
and we need to look after them and keep
them safe and give them some decent
accommodation
they want to work here they want to live
in the district they want to work in the
district
and we need to make that a bit more
amenable for them
so i support this council stewart
about the temporary accommodation 85k
where is that is it we're about to
temporary accommodation
we are just closing out on temporary
accommodation
leases and fit outs there are three
properties that we are
looking at and and the context of that
is that
we are looking at delivering this
project in four
separate stages that is in addition to
the current
position while we are waiting so in
effect there's five stages
um that have in terms of here and now
the next wee while then the first stage
of the project and following through to
the final one
being the chambers so temporary
accommodation that we are
um closing out on our negotiations and
fit outs are percival street
uh above the bakery so that's a
a temporary um six to twelve month lease
there
uh durham street just to
adjacent to mackenzie williams
on the ground floor where stuff
newspaper
have been located that's looking at a
longer-term arrangement
given the project is no longer catering
to
the expansion of staff numbers that we
have over the coming
four or five years and we're looking at
a three-year lease with two rights of
renewal
of one year beyond that so a five-year
term there
and the third premises are in lamb house
which is the heritage building that was
refurbished with the facade retained the
hotel
with a new building behind that so we've
upstairs there
so some of our challenges of getting in
are around making sure our our dates are
there with
less with the lessor and the
refurbishment work that we need to do in
some cases
as well as the i.t provision and to make
that happen but all of those are
are now working their way through so
hopefully over the next three or four
weeks
um we will be able to make all of those
spaces available
thank you um i just really want to
reiterate that
um i did make
a comment that the staff were in 12
different places the other day
but it's actually only eight different
places
currently which is still quite a lot to
cope with
and even then when we get back into the
refurbished building
it's not going to be complete and i
would really
like to say to everybody that we really
need to start planning
to complete a proper civic precinct
along with the
library which will take a few years to
get underway
but i think we need to start fairly soon
because it will be suddenly it will be
four or five years and we'll still
we might have the roof needs to be
replaced or something like that
but we need to keep moving on
on the plans of the civic precinct and
the library combined
as soon as we get this up and running
this might write a reply we do have that
civic precinct group that
is working and doing exactly what uh
council water is talking about so that
will be uh
there will be some preparations for the
10-year plan that will go in there which
is uh
very very soon so just be aware that
that's coming and
that'll be part of the discussions of
the 10-year plan and whatever form that
will take but it's about the whole
precinct in the first place
and the girl building will become the
secondary to that whatever that whatever
is decided from there so
um just as long as we're all aware of
that all right i will put that all those
in favor
against kerry thank you
fighting 8.6 welcome sarah pages
483-2495
thank you the first report on
remuneration
this report advises the remuneration
rate for elected members from first
july this year to 30th of june next year
there has been no changes to the
remuneration rate this financial year
from the remuneration authority
we're also required to review our
expenses policy which is forwarded to
the
remuneration authority and we've made no
changes to this policy
that the council adopted in november
beginning of this term i'll take the
report as read
and open for any questions do we have
any questions for sarah
appear to be nun do we have a movie
moved councillor blackie
seconded council award councillor
blackie nothing to ask you about really
council award i won't argue either
any further speakers appear to be none
i'll put that all those in favor
those against carried
thank you all right item 8.7
okay the representation review so
every six years we're required to review
the representation arrangement for the
district
which um approximately is an 18-month
project
with some set timelines at this point
we're not anticipating great change
perhaps minor boundary adjustments
however as we assess the census data
that's released in late september
and progress through the process of
community feedback on
on the number of wards elected members
names of wards
and boards the whole process will become
clearer
to assist with formulating the way the
special consultative procedure questions
to the community will develop the
council views
we will start with a working party so
today we're seeking three councillors
one from each ward to join the working
party
the mayor will be a member of that
working party
and we're also seeking one board member
to be appointed by the boards from
each area to be on that working party
the working party will report back to
the council at various stages through
the project
and then late next year we will get to a
point
that the council will have considered
all the information
hearings they'll make a recommendation
that will go out to the community again
with what the final
thing is we wait until there's any
appeals
and then that will take us through to
about christmas
and then the following january
everything is sent
to the local government commission they
assess
our whole process and then if there are
appeals they will
make the final decision on the overall
representation of the district
so happy to take any questions
could we alter that slightly to include
the deputy mayor as
as of right and exclude him from being a
councillor in on the on the um
on the relevant um community board
we have the mayor representing the the
at large
uh part of the district and the
councillors were really looking
at per ward for that representation of
per ward
and and the same with the community
boards um
it's entirely up to the council on how
they decide on that um
there is a balance on a working party
size as well
and ultimately the feedback will come
back to the council
to make any further decisions on but
it's up to the council today
if they wish to amend that um
the deputy mayor may become on there
um as a ward councillor so
custody thank you uh just
asking the question would you be
interested in people counselors around
here
putting their names forward as um
of interest what we're seeking today is
three councillors one from each ward and
whether you wish to break into a
workshop or take a moment to
have all your names sort of discussed is
entirely up to the chair
and yourselves
you can either just having to get right
we'll adjourn to a workshop we are now
attuned
to a workshop well what we're seeking is
names
um
yes
one of the things out that the meetings
will be most likely held on thursday
mornings and that's partly the workflow
and the mayor's availability as well so
you do need to be available on thursday
morning
and the other thing is too that it um
you want some new people sarah it
doesn't matter if everyone's new
um and i mean you but it would be kind
of good to have some experience
the people someone that's been there
before would that be is that advisable
or not
yes a good mix of fresh new ideas
thinking outside the square as well as
um
understanding some of the process okay
it is very much a numbers exercise at
the end of the day
that's true so paul paul was
eliminated from the discussion and the
name in the hats
so you've now got just just be where all
sorts of gender balances yeah i would
like to bring that up
sorry yeah make sure that there isn't
gender balance
it's gonna be hard to get a gender
balance with three people yeah oh i
don't know how that's gonna work
i'm sorry i totally disagree because it
unbalances the working party
you need to only have one representative
from each other
i agree but it's you're going to be
elected in so
if there's two excuse me hang on a
minute can you use your light please
just because he didn't you can because
this is not about who did or didn't
can you please use your lights
right counselor thank you yes i've put
my name forward because i would like to
represent the top half of the
waimakariri
right we're gonna we're gonna need to
make a decision because equally the
counselor uh mailings is going to say i
need to represent the
now and and again what philip is raising
is the fact that you do have
um two community boards now we're not
talking about community boards we're
talking about
council so we need to make sure because
each
each community board will have a
representative as well
that may very well be a council law
that says it can't be
okay my my reason for interest in this
is that i took quite an interest in our
last representation review
from outside of council for our current
ward structure
and as our award is um
quite interestingly constructed of like
say
the the ohoco subdivision as an example
we hold one quarter of the population
sorry we hold one half of the population
and one quarter of the area
and it's a fast growing area and i think
that we really need to pay some very
close attention to that and how it's
represented
anyone can attend the workshop
simple really show of hands
okay so for the ward of
uh we have both councillors for the ward
of
oxford and uh mirror and mirabelle
maybe it will be miraval one day but
and um show of hands
for uh wendy
one two there two there and uh for nicki
right so so be it
boy is phillip and myself um show of
hands
phillip one there
two there show of hands for neville
and that's neville now i just want to
reiterate there
anyone is able to attend the workshop
and have have input
it's just around that consensus voting
that um that that will be
um and no we're not having a vote for
paul because he's he's got it already
[Laughter]
any further questions on that report
appear to be numb do we have a mover
inserting the names
neville sorry
councillor atkinson council mailings
and council williams
right do we have a mover moved
councillor williams seconded uh
councillor barnett
any discussion there is none i'll put
that all those in favor
against carrie thank you
8.85 pages 506 to 516.
um yes thank you
simon as well so thank you this is a
report which
reflects a series of recommendations
from
greater christchurch partnership to the
council
about both the partnerships priorities
and funding arrangements that have been
proposed and i
and i believe we have talked about these
in a previous staff briefing session
firstly in terms of greater christchurch
partnership priorities they've
identified
five areas that we that
they think we should focus on as
uh priorities for the coming year
about developing greater christchurch
2050 which is a vision and plan for
the greater christchurch area and
engaging the community about that
secondly focusing on the urban growth
agenda
and trying to partner with government to
actually
get partnersh genuine partnership with
government on
matters that are critical to greater
christchurch which at the moment
we don't engage in as well as we perhaps
would like to
the third area is strengthening
relationships with manifeno
while we have three representatives from
the eewee and they represent
hapu and runanga within the greater
christchurch area
we don't maximize the value of that
relationship
to the extent we could and there's a
desire to
further build that and ensure that there
is stronger alignment
the fourth area is
the commitment to what would be seen as
business as usual the our space
plan of work they transport
initiatives that are many and varied
whether they be public transport
mass rapid transit uh the
construction of the program of works
that will see
for us the completion of the northern
corridor and making that operate and
work successfully
that's still really important to greater
christchurch and the partners
specifically for us
trying to promote the
regional policy statement change and
therefore the district plan change that
will enable zoning
in rangiora and kaiapoi
is a clear priority for us but there are
other matters across the partnership
were each
equally important and they are now
complicated by
the mps on urban development and
whether they're going to be further
complicated but by any rma reform
time will tell and the the final
element of focus is around recovery
from covert and we're not quite sure
what we're recovering from yet
and if there is needed to be
an extensive recovery program
particularly
the value of greater christchurch 2050
in terms of setting
a vision and plan for greater
christchurch is seen as really important
the greater christchurch 2050
vision and plan was a piece of work that
is seen as essential by the partnership
but as one that hasn't yet
been uh hadn't been taken into account
in any budgets and
it is urgent and the partnership agreed
that unless that is progressed
then the visible the clear and visible
leadership that is needed for greater
christchurch
won't be provided
after an assessment of what's needed to
actually develop that
vision and plan and engage the community
uh the partnership will advise that it's
probably in the order of one and a half
million dollars that is needed but was
in nobody's budget
through discussion and suggestion
he can have taken up the offer
of uh acting as banker for that project
and and seeking uh and paying for the
costs of it
uh but then uh recovering those from
christchurch selwyn and waimakariri in
parts equal to their
agreed contributions over
over five years for us that's in the
order of about a hundred and sixty
six thousand dollars
uh that will need to be factored into
our long-term plan budget when that
comes back to you there is a little bit
of capacity in that budget
at the moment but it will depend on what
other priorities greater christchurch
also identify
whether that be urban growth partnership
priorities or
their continuing business as usual
priorities which are still reasonably
significant
and onerous we think that was a really
good
solution and one that ecan
has resolved
about 10 days ago to
sign up to and christchurch city
likewise
last week have agreed to this as well um
today we consider it and so and
considers that matter
next week it's worth noting
that we will need as part of the ltp
plan
process to actually be reflecting on
what is the
value the con the further contributions
required to actually deliver
on uh our greater christ church
vision and objectives and that will come
back to you
and as part of what were some reasonably
tense negotiations over funding
uh there is also a recognition by the
partnership
that the current funding allocation
perhaps isn't the most
equitable across greater christchurch
uh he can and christchurch both pay
seven and a half percent of the costs
and
waimakariri and salwan um pay
12 and a half and the partnership has
asked the chief executive group by the
end of the year to provide a
further review of that and and that
may you know in all likelihood that
we'll see a
a request for us to be making a greater
contribution in that space
so uh there is
my sense of the partnership at the
moment is that it is in a good
it is a good space the partnership
committee is working well together
and is quite excited or
keen to see the work of greater
christchurch 2050 done which
i think the final comment the 2050 work
the while it will have a four
well-beings focus
at the moment we we run the risk of
christchurch
being um known pretty much
not for anything particularly
spectacular
and will and will become a little bit
more of a retire has the risk of
becoming a retirement village for
canterbury without
without us accentuating what the real
uh positives and opportunities are for
christchurch and
to that end there is work being
developed
in an economic space about what are
being
termed supernodes so creating four
supernodes for greater christchurch
one around food and fibre and utilizing
the
the skill that is and
technology and application of that
research skill and technology uh to our
benefit that
is particularly housed in the
universities the cris in the broader
canterbury rural landscape or hinterland
so food and fibre the second one is
health research
there is a significant
and applied
research community already in
christchurch the third which is an
evolving one which
surprises me but a number are quite
excited about the potential is actually
aerospace
and what we can do in both aeronautical
and aerospace
uh development and the fourth is one
we hide under our bushel quite a bit in
canterbury
all of those need to be supported by
high quality i.t
we currently have about 15 000 it
workers software developers in greater
christchurch working
and you wouldn't know it when you look
around
we have the potential to actually both
be building those other super nodes
and and uh talking up
the quality of rit uh community and the
the opportunity that's here to actually
create both
economic opportunity increase average
wage which is actually quite low
relative to other metropolitan areas in
new zealand
and actually building building something
that says yes when you think about
christchurch you think about these
things
as well as it being a great place to
live for all of the other
environmental and social benefits that
it provides so
i think it's a really important piece of
work yes it costs a lot of money
there is quite an engagement plan that
is going with this that will come out
end of september and october
to engage the community about what it
thinks
of the ideas that are being developed
and by early next year we should be in a
place to have that
2050 program of work um drawing to a
close
so thank you i'm happy to take any
questions
on the report or the recommendations
council williams
yeah um 1.7 million dollars odd
is that just all consultants
bureaucratics or is that paying for
staff to run these meetings what what's
what's actually going
there's no physical um
stuff that's actually coming out there
that i can see anyway um
and i'll presume christchurch will
provide their staff and their counselors
when they want to we will as well we
won't be charging for that so
where is that 1.7 million dollars going
towards you know is there anything
physical
does it does it build anything other
than a vision and a plan
um and in the community engagement
around it
no it doesn't and the the question you
raised is one that the partnership
raised the chief executives raves the
senior managers have raised as well and
uh asked for a breakdown of the costs
related to that
it is it is a combination of staff and
consultant cost that is makes that up
it sounds it sounds a
significant sum of money um not that not
that that's necessarily the baseline
that we should be thinking about but
most of the other significant planning
and engagement
pieces of work that we've had in greater
christchurch
and through recovery well since
since the earthquake and recovery and
our our
red zone plan was an example of that
that was
um about a million dollars and that's
the cheapest one that
um was delivered across greater
christchurch through to christchurch's
red zone plan in the order of about
five million dollars i believe
regenerate spent
so uh it is it is it feels
eye watering i get that there is um
there is a team of about five
people who are working away on it at the
moment
um and there will be a whole lot more
coming to it
um as as the program builds
can i just add to that if you don't have
this plan
you can kiss your government funding
goodbye because the government requires
it
that we work together and that we form
the plans together
and if you have a look around
certainly north island areas and places
that have these plans in place
and have a look at where the
government's funding going is going and
i'm not talking about covet
i'm talking about normal day work what
is that
normal days work if you don't have these
plans
then last time we did this plan was
150 154 million or 54 million i can't
remember which
in roading that came um
yeah so so that's the that's just
yeah i wasn't saying against it i
i was just trying to think how we can
justify that amount of money because
it's an
awful lot of money for bureaucrats
thank you i noticed some
number little three is to strengthen the
partnership with manufa
niwi um
what happens we've got mahitahi uh and
you know executive meeting monthly what
do the other councils have
with um uh not what's not to
know to him
there are different um arrangements in
place
ecan has a two-year
program where the ten papatipurunga
cheers
meet with the ecan council
uh reasonably regularly i'm not sure i
can't recall the frequency but
that they meet them they they have an
engagement at that level
christ church has six papa tipu runanga
um including naituriri but
the best of them the rest are mainly
around the peninsula
so they meet
again six weekly
gear pretty pretty pretty regularly
again that is the chairs of those
uh arena others
probably don't have the same level of
regular engagement as us
would be my sense of it but um
i know kaikoura having had a
a bit of a rocky road with in their
relationship with
uh that that they work with
they are now um putting a lot more
effort into that relationship in a
meeting quite often
um so it's v it's it's dif you know
each are different um and
the the the issue with greater christ
church is there are
six papa tipu runanga that we need to
work with across
greater christchurch and
make sure that we are connected we have
three representatives of
ewe who do represent some of those
but not necessarily all of them um
and and how to ensure that the
aspirations
which
have for the greater christchurch region
are aligned and make
sure that we're working on in their best
interests as well as
you know as part of the broader
community's best interests so
we are meeting as a group of chief
executives with
representatives next 17th that is
to talk about how that partnership can
further be strengthened
they're quite positive about it and
even just as of yesterday talking about
three waters which we might talk about
more when there's an agenda item later
in the later in the papers uh to
talk about that and the way in which
we're trying to build
and strengthen relationship with
manafenoua
comments there is is there any
articulation
um from monophenol about what
would their preferred
solution would be to this engagement or
how they see the shape of it
it's it's possibly too early but
what they do want to be involved is
early
and deeply and enough genuine
partnership sense
and the thought of them being viewed as
a stakeholder is something which
upsets them they're not just any other
party
simon has a comment there too probably
also
the specific outcome that i think
they're going to seek most out of this
is housing and we
are with maori reserve 873
possibly the most interested and
affected area in that
conversation uh and
i think actually we if through the
through the gcp work we could get
uh we could get some traction uh
in some of the things that we want to
and
frankly need to do in terms of mr873
one other very quick comment if you
recall the
three the kind of tenor of the rma
reform announcement
last week then this is an investment in
the future with
uh manafenua because the relationship in
planning terms will only become
more and more significant over time and
as you know those folk work on
relationships
and this is an investment in the future
in that regard
just just about that amount of money
that we were just talking about um that
everybody's eyes watered a little bit
with
now it was my understanding as well am i
wrong here that
that that amount also includes um
money towards raising awareness as in
like consultation advertising what not
for just what the greater christchurch
partnership is because
most people out there have no idea they
haven't actually heard of it and they
don't know
who we are what we do and what we're
trying to achieve so
just just to be clear the
the um the the cost of the gcp
2050 project is estimated at 1.5 million
there is some funding available within
its existing kitty so we need about
another 1.18 million
as what is being sought but yes it is
and and that
funding is for all of those things as
well as
trying to tell the story of greater
christchurch and
demonstrating greater visible leadership
at the moment apart from
the partners not many people other than
those who are deeply interested not many
people actually know about
the work of the greater christchurch
partnership or the value that it
that it is and should be bringing to
greater christchurch because i think
until we get some traction with our
people
that you know again who and what great
greater christchurch partnership is
we are not going to get any attraction
with the central government on these
projects we're not going to get their
attention if we can't get our own
people's attention
so um good question do you believe
right that is good to know that there is
thank you for answering my question jim
that there's some um there is a myriad
of recommendations
here someone prepared to move
moved to council brian i'm happy to
second
council well um
to me no brain has been used a few times
today this
is a is a no-brainer in the interests of
of the partnership um and greater
christchurch
i can't add any more than that it's
unfortunate
the amount of amount of money but if
you get a group of chief executives and
team
sit down and say this is the amount of
money that we need to invest
to get this project
operating as we want it to operate and
extolling the virtues of the greater
canterbury partnership then i'm not
going to argue with a group of very
experienced
chief executives to as i say
yeah just to add to that i i was sitting
around the regeneration table in the
very first part when
and certainly mr markham was there as
well we had a budget of 900 000 and we
thought our
contribution to that was thousand to 600
a recovery plan
and i can still remember benicious
benisha smith sitting across the table
from us and said
i don't know what you're thinking
because we've never delivered a plan
under a million dollars yet
and we did it um so it gives you some
idea of the eye-watering numbers that go
around these plants and things
necessary or not i'm i'm unsure wasted
money sometimes or
or best money again i'm a little unsure
but um
what i can tell you is that it is is the
necessary beast of democracy
and uh this is one of those things that
i think that
we in this district will actually
benefit from we do benefit from the
greater christchurch partnership i have
no doubt in my mind about that being
part of it and
being on the inside um
at that table we do benefit from that
and from
some of the uncomfortable discussions
that we have around that table
we have come out okay just about every
time so
you know there's further work to be done
and there will still be uncomfortable
conversations to be had but this sets us
on
on the same railway track as everybody
else i i would hope
any further speakers councillor duty
and this is this is an opportunity to
promote
the whole of wider canterbury um for
job seekers especially those that are
professionals that have come from
overseas that have got
they're cashed up and ready to somewhere
to
reside and work and i mean it was just
in the paper the other day about the
american couple that
one was new zealand and they came over
they've settled in christchurch then
they've chosen christchurch as a
great place to be and this is what's all
about us to make our
area known as a good place to live and
bring up your children
so for me this is just the no-brainer to
promote
speakers
okay i'll put that all those in favor
against
carried thank you uh item nine
uh nothing referred from the community
boards that we have on our agenda
item 10.1 health and safety mr palmer 5
517-527
thank you
other than other than noting
the issues we've had with rangiora
service center which you're well aware
of
there are no other matters to be brought
to your attention in this report that
should cause you concern thank you mr
many questions questions
council stuart the um
the net that was turned a near miss but
the staff member that was getting into
the
kyber wastewater treatment plant without
um
without a key um for the bird counts i
thought that went out to
someone else but um were they
getting through after the new fencing
i honestly don't don't know
okay yeah i've got it too
yeah yes
um no sorry it's a city council staff
member that was getting in that was the
guy that's
meant to be to do their botulism dead
bird counts
and we did the fencing so he must have
been hooping through the
the new the old or is that the new
fencing i'd be a bit worried
because we've just upgraded all that and
they've just found that he was getting
them without a
key yes don't know there's still
an open matter that needs some further
investigation don't like i don't know
rather than debate that here i think mr
palmer will bring that back to us next
time i think that's
the easiest way council williams my
concerns of the worker um
at the um the
um was that worker in the water when
they had the um
fit the seizure
i don't believe so
because that would be a
thank you council blackie chickens that
nearly got onto the road have had
counselling
and been and seen the error of their
ways
they've now crossed the road
safely on the other side council bunny
oh mine was a little bit more serious
about the chickens i'm
just the response that they don't deal
with chickens
surely if there's a hazard to life
someone should deal with it so
well that response is what do they call
police what happens
because it's dangerous
do you bring out the shotgun but i mean
someone should deal with it
animal control shouldn't just say they
don't deal with it surely
is that an nzta meta is it a police
meter
no it's a safety matter
i think the response needs to be better
than that i think look there's a
question raised i think that um
both of those are a short line and the
next one mr burma might just
help us through um
yeah okay all right i think that's just
probably the best
moved just just on that you can just
just on that chicken one you need to be
careful what we're talking about there
because we've got
um you know the um
um running running around by the skew
bridge and
a lot of places rear so we could create
a
nightmare um that's all
thank you moved moved
uh i'm sorry moved council awards second
to the council of duty
council award do you wish to no thank
you
i'll put that all as in favor against
carrick yeah
all right we have a series of i put some
glasses on so i can see what i'm doing
we have a series of minutes for
information there someone prepared to
move on
block 11.1 to 11.4 moved to council
abandoned secondary council award
is there any discussion around those i
will put those all those in favor
against carried thank you
the community board minutes for
information
is there anything that needs to be
raised from anyone around the table on
any of those
council williams
while you're looking for that i have no
number 13
i have no reports for information
and we'll leave that open council
williams
while you're looking for that and item
14.1
the mia's diary moved by council black
is seconded by
uh councillor redmond is there any
discussion on the mayor's diary appears
to be none i'll put that all those in
favor
against carried right we'll go back
council williams have you found your
spot
foreign
so that's been referred to the community
board's dealing with that rather than us
okay so that but that's been dealt with
by the community board
yes okay thank you radio all right can
we have a move before uh
uh from 12.1 to 12.4
moved by council william signatures by
council stewart
is there any discussion appears to be
none i will put those all those in favor
against carried now in light of
time can we please even though we need
our updates can we please keep them
brief
so that we can move into the public
excluded with the
particularly with the extra item that we
have on there so
just brief comments if we may uh
councillor stewart on the
council sorry on the water management
thank you mr deputy mayor and there is
quite a bit of stuff that
has happened in my portfolios so i'll
just rip
through them um the canterbury water
management strategy there is
ecanna's refo proposed a new term a
reference for
the function of zone committees moving
from planning to implementation and
ecan has a proposed letter of shared
priorities which i
i presume mr palmer is going to come to
us as a workshop or a briefing because
we
we have to as a council um to go off
some of this
so um in the light that you'll be um in
water
oh is that good um yes so there's
um um there's as i said a change of
terms of reference for the zone
committees
um they are asked to um
to create an action plan
and um yeah so i'll leave that um there
was a
uh also a presentation or
request from the iken youth rupu
who is a group of young people who are
interested in
joining the zone committee
with a seat on the zone committee
representing young people and uh voting
rights they've already um
uh got a position on the christchurch
um west melton uh committee
they say they gave quite a good
presentation yesterday they
would like the voice of youth
to be reflected in the decisions on
order management
which are going to affect them in their
future
so again i think that'll come to us to
talk about as well we had a six monthly
update
on all the work that ecan and wdc
have done implementing the zone
implementation
program addendum and i just like to
congratulate wdc staff who aren't here
but
have done a really good job ecan
is um is catching up and you'd like to
know that the
economy spent 150 000 on 15
000 plants in the silver stream
um loop uh that's that 27
kilometer loop track that we've been
talking about for years and they're
going to get it finished in the next
five years
um michael bait came with some video on
the taranaki stream
quite a concerning section of downstream
of ravenswood and it looks like
someone's been out there with a spray
again and
it is through the private area of
the ravenswood development downstream
from
mcdonald's he had pictures of lovely
weed and then nothing and then
further down more weed growing so
that's being investigated um
on the biodiversity front um
i and many other councillors helped with
the plantings in the honda forest for
the last couple of saturdays
the zone committee set up a biodiversity
sub
group which is just getting its legs
and one of the interesting things that
came out there was
uh considering that the community
service awards that we
have actually extends from
and i know sometimes there have been
groups
but uh actually commend a
biodiversity project within the um
region we have an award for the best now
it can either come under i suggested
community service awards or
that we could set up an award which that
group was quite keen on
to celebrate the very best biodiversity
project within the district and tomorrow
night
at kpa in the coast guard
at 5 30 sophie allen and
adrian meredith from ekin will be
talking about the kaiapoi river so
um if you want to hear the latest
come along there thank you any questions
thank you sandra uh international
relations
um it's not a huge big
busy time uh apart from knowing when
borders are up now
in saying that we had a uh both dan and
i had a conversation with
uh freddie the clerk um
and uh he as well and uh going to start
working on um some relationships between
kaiapoi high school and
high school over there so um where
they are and and you know the areas
better than i jim
um but in the areas where they directly
are they don't have a high school so
they actually
their students go outside there to go to
high school but
trying to hook up certainly kaiapoi high
school in the early stages of
through the rsa and in kaiapoi to
um to get their relationship back off
the ground that was
working until unfortunately the loss of
kevin brown
so they hope to get that going again
so that's that's me on that one uh
council of blackie regeneration
um dredging is finished last wednesday
and duncan's pleased with the and with
the result of that
the piles in the river start work
tomorrow or thursday
uh thursday i think it is so that's
underway
um as sandra's just said honda forest
has had three planting days now
quite well attended one more to go um
cure boat club is coming down although
there's been no action in the building
for
several days now it seems to have
stopped but the demolition's
well underway in the east area roads
um the road all the roads will be
finished um before the end of september
as you know the weather's got in the way
of them a bit but they're they're coming
along
the norman kirk reserve the whole area
um
we want to we're thinking starting to
think about an opening for that just
putting your thinking caps on as to what
we've got a problem with fitting it in
amongst all the other things in the in
the district
but we'd like to have an hour an hour
and a half long sort of a
ceremony come demonstration game on the
new playing fields whatever
just have a thought about what you think
would be good for that and when we could
fit it in
and that's me thank you
councilman
um look i guess i too will be brief um
we've already heard um extensively what
has been happening in the climate change
space today so i'll leave that at that
and i'm aside from my question at the
beginning of the meeting regarding the
sustainability
steering group i'm going out to
community boards which i hope that
all of the community board agendas will
be amended so that that will
be included in their agenda items
because we need to appoint a member from
each
each community board and that needs to
happen sooner than later so we can get
this off the ground so i'd very much
like to see that happen please
i have received a couple emails from the
public supporting the creation of that
sustainability steering group
um you probably did too as well i take
it
which which is good i've heard nothing
but positive
things from from the community in in
regards to that space
and um other than that over um
the last month i attended a meeting
of resilient hiranui which also um
councillor redmond and grant edge from
ikean also attended which was really
fascinating i did send you guys all
through the um the copy of the report
that came through to that
it is interesting bedtime reading but it
is well worth the read it's quite
interesting
they're having another meeting on the
20th of august at 7 30
at amberley school if anybody um wants
to go and have a look but i think that
the creation of a group like that is
something that would be really good for
us to have here in in this district
um they they're very well attended there
were 60 people there
so uh you know there's obviously
interest and that's that's
so um but the the subject of the the
next one is actually going to have a
speaker that
is talking about how another council has
combined regional climate modeling and
stakeholders insights
to um support decision making there so
it could be interesting for us but
anyhow that is
all i have to say so thanks question
councilman
just said she just with your indulgence
from an
a covered response generator we had
before i didn't quite get
signal you quick enough but just to note
there's a social recovery workshop on
9 to 12 this week and we and would end
about covered social recovery
that all members are invited to attend
and can talk to nikki carter if they'd
like to attend
thank you for that so that's thursdays
till 12 at woodland community centre
perhaps you might send just a quick note
to councillors on that if you wouldn't
mind adrian
thank you
right i have no questions
i have no uh urgent general business
now we we're going to move into
into committee could we have a mover for
what's uh moved by councillor barnett
and seconded by councillor blackie um
we'll just make sure we're now in
committee oh sorry i'll put that all
those in favor
against carrie thank you we're now in
committee so just make sure the live
stream there is uh
is now cut now um
do you want how long do you want to have
a look at this uh the paper you have in
front of you
i'm in your hands here i mean we can do
it in 10
or we can do it in half an hour it's
your call i want to make sure that
everybody's
got the information they need from the
information
that's in front of them so um your call
let me know what is it
those who want 10 minutes ends up
who wants 10 one who wants half an hour
who wants 20 minutes 20 minutes
one sorry of the
10 20 or half an hour make up your mind
yep shovel really okay
okay 20 minutes we've got right so grab
a cup of tea or whatever and then
we're back here on the dot
you